ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON OWN
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
REYES REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND AND TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
LET US ME VISIT AGAIN. SEVENTEEN
FILLABLE HAIKU BY THE POOR POET
BILL CONTAI [inaudible]
SHOWING FRONT [inaudible]
SHOWING BACK.
MAPLE LEAVES FALL.
TRUE HAIKU IS AN EXPERIENCE OF
NATURALNESS.
OF THINGS JUST AS THEY ARE.
IN THIS MAPLE LEAF HAIKU.
THE LEAVES ARE NOT HOLDING ONTO
THE CHEESE THING I DON'T WANT TO
GO.
THE TREES ARE NOT HOLDING ON TO
THE LEAD THING YOU BELONG TO ME.
THE LEAVES JUST PAUL WITHOUT
PRETENSION.
WITHOUT ATTACHMENT [inaudible]
INTERESTING INTERESTINGLY.
YOUR BILL CONDON TYPE WHO WAS
CALLED THE WHY SCHOOL. FOR IN
HIS LIFETIME HE REFUSED TO BE
HONORED AS A POET.
A TEACHER OR A PHILOSOPHER.
YUKON LIVED WITHOUT ATTACHMENT.
LIKE THE TREES HAVING TO LET GO
THEIR LEAVES.
AND THE LEAVES HAVING TO LET GO
OF THE TREE BRANCHES.
WE NOTED IN LIVING THROUGH THE
SEASONS OF LIFE.
WE MUST ALL IN TIME HAVE TO LET
GO OF PEOPLE WE LOVE.
IN TIME WE MUST ALSO THE GOAL OF
LIFE ITSELF.
ALL.
WE WISH YOU DID NOT HAVE TO BE
SO.
AND ALWAYS EXPERIENCING TRUE
LAW.
IS THE HARDEST THING WE WILL
EVER HAVE TO KNOW IN LIVING
LIFE.
THIS AUTUMN.
EACH TIME WE SEE OF THE FALL.
LET US IMAGINE IT IS NATURE'S
REMINDER. TO LIVE FULLY EVERY
SCENE EVERY YEAR WE ARE ABLE TO
ENJOY.
NATURE IS ALWAYS ENCOURAGING
HAVE TO LIVE WITH OUR WISDOM
EYES OPEN.
NUMBER.
ONE WITH KINDNESS INGRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER.
ONE PLEASE PAY PLACE SURE HAND
OVER YOUR HEART AND JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
STATE.
INTO THE ROOT PROBLEM
[inaudible] ONE NATION
[inaudible]
IT IS [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SEVEN MINUTE
NINETY AMPARO KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK READING QUICK
KATHLEEN I'M LUIS READING THE
ROLES CALLED.
MEASURE CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THERE ARE KNOW ABSENCES FOR
TODAY'S SESSION
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LOTS A BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY TODAY PLEASE
REPORT TO THE FLOOR
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ TO SPEAK
ON IN THE GERMAN AND MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE ENACT A
FILE ITEMS NUMBER NUMBER TWO OF
TWO S. B.. NINE FIFTY ONE
MITCHELL ITEM ONE SEVENTY S. B.
TEN THIRTY EIGHT LEYVA AND ITEM
THREE OH NINE S. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN HERNANDEZ.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
ROLE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM RESCINDING MY PREVIOUS
RE REFER ALL OF SP TWELVE SIXTY
JACKSON. TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
AND I AM ORDERING OF THE BILL
BACK TO THE THIRD READING FILE.
I AM ALSO REVISING MY EARLIER RE
REFERRAL OF SP FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE CANNELLA. TO THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
AND THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE SO THE BILL IS NOW
ONLY REFERRED TO THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
ALSO MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I AM REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS.
TO COMMITTEES ITEM.
ONE TWENTY ONE AB FOURTEEN FORTY
FIVE REYES TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT S. B. SIX
SO SEVEN SKINNER. TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MISTER
CALDERON YOU AGAIN RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT ROLE SIX TWO WAY
THE FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT. FOR
THE FOLLOWING BIT COMMITTEES TO
MEET. TO ALLOW THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO HEAR S.
B. ONE TWENTY ROTH ON TUESDAY
AUGUST.
TWENTY EIGHT UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION IN ROOM FOUR FORTY SEVEN
TO ALLOW THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS TO HEAR.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
CANNELLA ON TUESDAY AUGUST
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
FORTY FORTY FIVE RAY AS AN SP
ONE FIFTY TWO MCGUIRE ON
TUESDAY.
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT AT NINE A.
M. IN ROOM FOUR FORTY SEVEN AND
TO ALLOW THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TO HEAR S. B. SIX OR SEVEN
SKINNER TODAY UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION.
AND ROOM.
FOR FORTY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE PLEASE REMOVE
ITEM FOR SIXTEEN SPR THIRTY
MCGUIRE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SEVERAL FOR NINETEEN WITH THE
MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO START AT
SENATE THIRD READING.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
NINE THIS IS SB [inaudible]
ELEVEN FORTY FIVE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
SPEAKER MEMBERS S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY FIVE AUTHORIZES ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS OR E. I. F. DIS TO DO
MAINTENANCE ON THE FACILITIES
THEY BUILT.
CITIES AND COUNTRIES ARE
COUNTIES CAN CREATE E. AYE OF
DIS TO PAY FOR OB PROJECTS.
SUCH AS WATER SYSTEMS CHILDCARE
FACILITIES PARKS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
PRESENTLY E. I. F. PEACE CANNOT
PAY FOR MAINTENANCE ROUTINE
REPAIRS OR OPERATIONS.
THIS SITUATION IS PROBLEMATIC
SINCE MANY COMMUNITIES ONE NAY
FUNDS FROM THESE DISTRICT TO
MAINTAIN THE STRUCTURES OVER
TIME.
SB ELEVEN FORTY FIVE ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROACTIVELY
BUDGET MAINTENANCE COSTS FROM
THE E. I. F. DIS REVENUES RATHER
THAN RELY ON UNCERTAIN GENERAL
FUNDS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ASK FOR NEW
FUNDS TAXES OR FEES.
S. B. LOVER FORTY FIVE SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION.
ARE STRICTLY OUT FOR OUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
EYES [inaudible]
FORTY THREE KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE PASS RETAIN FILE ITEMS ONE
SIXTY AND?
ONE SIXTY ONE WE AREN'T FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO S. B..
TEN THIRTY FIVE CORKERY SENATE
BILL TEN THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND ACTUALLY THE LAND
USE.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SP TEN THIRTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES THE CLEAR FREQUENT
INFLEXIBLE UPDATE REQUIREMENT
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO FOLLOW
IN ADDRESSING CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY IN THEIR GENERAL
PLANNING.
THIS BILL DIRECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO UPDATE THE SAFETY
ELEMENT OF THE GENERAL PLAN FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY STRATEGIES THAT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO.
SO UPON EITHER AN UPDATE OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT OR THEIR LOCAL
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN WHICH
EVER SERVES THEIR LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS BETTER.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR GOT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SERIOUSLY
THOROUGHLY AND COMPREHENSIVELY
AND REGULARLY ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE LONG RANGE
PLANNING.
THIS BILL ACHIEVES THAT GOAL WAS
STILL ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE FLEXIBILITY.
A TIME THEIR UPDATES THIS BILL
HASHAD NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER KERSEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB MARIAH ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL-ON EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS [inaudible]
ONE SIXTY THREE THROUGH. ONE
EIGHTY ONE WERE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM WHEN
AB.
TWO PASS A RETAIN FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY THREE WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY THREE COOPERATE
SAMPLE EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND I
PLAN TO EMERGENCIES.
MS I YEAR CURRY MAKE AN OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THERE IS NO STATE STANDARDS FOR
HOW EMERGENCY EVACUATION ALERTS
ARE DEPLOYED ACROSS THE STATE.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY THREE WILL
CREATE STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
EVACUATION ALERT GUIDELINES AND
TRAININGS.
UNDER THE BILL OWE YES WILL WORK
WITH TECHNICAL EXPERTS TO
DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR ALERTING
THE PUBLIC OF AN EMERGENCY. OH
YES IS ALSO WILL ALSO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE TRAINING FOR LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS.
AFTER THE GUIDELINES ARE
AVAILABLE.
WE MUST INVEST IN UPDATED
TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL HELP INSURE
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS RECEIVE
CRITICAL EMERGENCY INFORMATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU ABOUT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SIX PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN
A FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM POINT.
EIGHTY NINE THAT BRINGS US FILE
ITEM.
ONE NINETY S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
FOUR CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR PAN AND THAT'S GOING
TO THE INTERNET [inaudible]
MISTER CHAU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER SP FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
DIRECTS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY GROUP TO
STUDY THE SPREAD OF FALSE
INFORMATION.
THROUGH INTERNET BASED SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS AND DRAFT A
pTHE SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
THROUGH PLATFORMS.
THERE'S A CLEAR ISSUE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE SPREAD OF FALSE
INFORMATION.
IN MARCH OF A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SCIENCE MAGAZINE REPORTED ON THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE
DIFFERENTIAL DIFFUSION OF ALL OF
THE VERIFY TRUE AND FALSE NEWS
STORIES.
DISTRIBUTED ON TWITTER FROM
200-062-2017.
THE FINDINGS SHOW THAT
FALSEHOODS DIFFUSED
SIGNIFICANTLY FARTHER FASTER
DEEPER AND MORE BROADLY THAN THE
TRUTH IN ALL CATEGORIES OF
INFORMATION.
SINCE SOCIAL MEDIA MORE WEBSITES
ON THE PLATFORMS FOR WHICH FALSE
INFORMATION SPREADS IT IS GOING
TO BECOME MORE IMPORTANT.
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING SEVERAL COMPANIES ARE
ALREADY COMING UP WITH PLANS TO
MITIGATE THE SPREAD OF FALSE
INFORMATION.
THE PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW WHAT
THOSE PLANS ARE AND IF THEY ARE
WORKING.
CONVENING A WORKING GROUP TO
STUDY THE SPREAD A FALSE
INFORMATION WILL BE THE FIRST
STEP.
IN WORKING TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
FALSE INFORMATION AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC FROM THE REAL THREATS
AND HARM THAT CAN COME FROM
FALSE INFORMATION.
OUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY WAS SPEAKING MEMBERS --
YOU WITH THIS BILL THE ONE THING
THAT I WOULD.
CAUTION IS ANYTIME AND CERTAINLY
WE'VE SEEN.
INCIDENTS OF FALSE THINGS BEING
SPREAD AROUND ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA AND AND WHAT'S TRANSPIRED
WITH THAT BUT TO THEN HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT START GAIN INTO THE
BUSINESS OF DETERMINING WHAT.
IS ACCURATE AND WHAT IS TRUE --
TO ME -- CAN
BECOME PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE MANY
TIMES ON SOME THE SUBJECTS THEY
CAN BE PEOPLE CAN HAVE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION.
AND GOVERNMENTS TEND TO BE MORE
POLITICAL --
AND I DON'T THINK THAT ANYONE.
ANYONE PARTY OR ANY --
ONE AGENCY.
HAS -- HOLD
ON THE TRUTH --
AND SO WE CAN GET IT CAN GET
KIND OF PROBLEMATIC WHEN WE
START PUTTING GOVERNMENT IN THAT
POSITION WHAT WE WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO DO IS ENSURE.
NOW WE HAVE AN EDUCATED POPULACE
THAT CAN DETERMINE FOR
THEMSELVES --
WHAT IS TRUE AND WHAT IS FALSE
IN THAT CAN DISCERN FOR
THEMSELVES --
WHAT IS YOU KNOW?
WHAT IS BACKED BY FACTUAL
INFORMATION WHAT IS NOT
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I AM A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED BY
THIS BILL IN THE DIRECTION IT'S
TAKING IS STARTING TO PUT THAT.
ON GOVERNMENT AND PUTTING
GOVERNMENT IN THAT POSITION
RATHER THAN LEAVING THAT TO
PEOPLE.
AND THE PUBLIC TO DO IT TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS AND THE AND
THE MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS. TO
EXPOSE THINGS THAT ARE FALSE TO
EXPOSE THINGS THAT ARE WRONG.
AND TO ACT ACCORDINGLY SO I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
DIRECTION THANK YOU.
SURE MATHIS YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS YOU KNOW THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION REMINDS ME OF OUR
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE BOOKS --
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY GEORGE
ORWELL.
IN A IN IN THEIR IT TALKS ABOUT
--
A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT MINISTRIES
PERMISSION HURRIED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU ONE OF THESE
MINISTRIES IS THE MINISTRY OF
TRUTH.
SHORTEN TO IN THEM MANY CHIU
DEALING.
WITH HISTORY ARE NEWS AND
EDUCATION THE MINISTRY OF TRUTH
AS A PROPAGANDA MACHINE.
THE IRONY IS THAT.
ALL IT DOES IS LAW.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE MINISTRY
OF TRUTH DOES TO ITS CITIZENS
MEMBERS.
LET'S NOT GO TO NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR ASK FOR NO VOTE.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
--
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE
A QUESTION OF THE AUTHORED BY ME
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SO THIS WOULD CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP RIGHT OKAY SO.
MY QUESTION IS.
WHO DECIDE LIKE WHAT'S THE
BACKGROUND WHERE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE ON THIS WORKING GROUP
WHAT WOULD --
ALLOW THEM TO BE CONSIDERED AS
EXPERTS OR PROFESSIONALS IN THE
AREA OF IDENTIFYING WHAT IS TRUE
AND NOT TRUE.
IN THE MEDIA.
MISTER CHAU.
OUR THE ADVISORY GROUP WILL
ESSENTIALLY BE COMPOSED SO FAR
AT LEAST ONE MEMBER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ALL ONE MEMBER FROM THE INTERNET
BASED SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDER.
AND ALSO ONE MEMBER FROM THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCATE AS WELL
AS A MEMBER FROM THE FIRST
AMENDMENT SCHOLARS SO.
SO YOU WILL HAVE A DIVERSE GROUP
OF PEOPLE FROM ALL.
WALKS OF LIFE ESSENTIALLY
BASICALLY GETTING TOGETHER TO
DETERMINE SOME OF THESE ISSUES
WOULD NOT TRY TO COME UP WITH
ACTUALLY.
ARM.
YOU KNOW RECOMMENDATION ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER BUT I THINK THIS IS
A STUDY BILL IS ISOLATE. TO FIND
OUT WHAT SOME OF THE POOR OF
POTENTIAL ISSUES ARE SAID THAT
THAT WE COULD.
MAYBE TAKE NICK THAT STEPS ARE
BASED UPON DOT.
SOSA DOT THE THAT'S HOW THAT
WORKS.
BUT MISS MELENDEZ YOU MAY
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER [inaudible]
SO.
BASED ON THAT DESCRIPTION IT
DOESN'T SOUND AS THOUGH THAT
PARTICULAR GROUP OF PEOPLE --
ARE ANY MORE QUALIFIED TO
IDENTIFY.
FALSE INFORMATION THAN ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM --
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S IT'S A
WORKING GROUP BUT WITH WORKING
GROUP CENTER ESTABLISH ALWAYS
COME ALONG SOME OTHER LAW THAT
FURTHER ESTABLISHES THE IS THIS
GROUPING TO DECIDING WHAT IS
TRUE AND WHAT IS UNTRUE.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT.
GIVEN WHAT I HAVE HEARD.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PANEL OF
EXPERTS WHO CAN FOLLOW THROUGH
ON ON THE DESIRE WHICH IS TO BE
ABLE TO HELP IDENTIFYING TEACHER
STUDENTS WHAT IS REAL.
AND WHAT IS NOT REAL --
THAT I MEAN.
RESPECTABLE PEOPLE WERE
MENTIONED BUT NOT NECESSARILY
QUALIFIED SO I'M NOT SURE THAT
THIS REALLY IS THE ANSWER TO THE
PROBLEM I THINK EVERYONE IN HERE
WOULD AGREE.
THAT THERE IS A BIG PROBLEM WITH
NEWS BEING DISPERSED OUT THERE
THAT IS UNTRUE PART OF THAT
COMES FROM --
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THIS THE MEDIA WHO.
IN THEIR EFFORTS TO BE FIRST --
AREN'T ALWAYS FACTUAL WHEN THEY
FIRST GET A STORY OUT AND THAT'S
A LOT OF TIMES HOW SOME OF THESE
FAKE NEWS STORIES CAN PERPETUATE
IS BECAUSE THEY START OFF YOU
KNOW.
THIS BAG END UP THIS BIG BUT I
JUST I DON'T I DON'T HEAR.
A COMPELLING ARGUMENT THAT THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP OF PEOPLE WOULD
BE ABLE TO COMBAT THIS PROBLEM I
THINK -- MRS
IS BETTER LEFT PERHAPS PERHAPS
THE TECHNOLOGY INC INDUSTRIES IN
THE NEWS ORGANIZATIONS AND TO
TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT THERE
CERTAINLY MORE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD THAT WE ARE SO WITH THAT
--
I WOULD ASK FOR NO VOTE.
DOCTOR QUIRK IRRITANTS --
I HAVE SOME COMMENTS THAT THE
FLOOR MANAGER CAN ANSWERING HIS
CLOSING.
WHEN IS THIS BILL IS ARM?
OPPOSED BY THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
OP WE ALREADY HAVE FACEBOOK AND
OTHERS.
DOING THEIR BEST TO KEEP --
AT LEAST.
CLANDESTINE GROUPS OFF THEIR
MEDIA.
ARM I DON'T THINK WE NEED A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY NOW --
TO COME UP WITH ADDITIONAL
GUIDELINES I THINK WE SHOULD
THINK IT'S TIME TO WAIT THANK
YOU.
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERS OF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
NOW.
DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I HAVE ARE.
QUESTION OR MAYBE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OF TO DEAL WITH --
WE DON'T ENGAGING COLLOQUY I'D
I'D ASK THAT YOU OKAY HOW IS
YOUR QUESTION WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE MISS CHAO MAKE YOU DANCE
RIGHT NOW OR IN HIS CLOTHES
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW HOW.
THIS IDEA.
I IS A DIFFERENTIATED.
OUR PHONE THE CENSORSHIP.
AND US SECONDLY YA
IMPRACTICALITY [inaudible]
THE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF WHAT
INFORMATION.
UP ON THE MEDIA.
HOW WITH THIS --
THE ADVISORY GROUP MONEY TO ALL
OF THOSE I DAY WANNA MONEY TO
SELECTIVELY.
THIS IS SAW.
YOU KNOW IMPRACTICAL INDIAN WITH
THE INFORMATION FAKE OR TRUTH OR
INFORMATION THAT THE WE FACE
EVERY DAY.
I URGE OF NO FAULT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
MISTER SHALL YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AND I A I THINK THEY'RE ONE OF
THE POINTS I WAS BEING REYES WAS
EDUCATION.
POINT BEING THAT WE NEED TO BE
EDUCATED ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT THIS IS MERELY A STUDY
BILL.
A STUDY BILL TO LOOK AT A VERY
REAL PROBLEM THAT HAS CREATED A
THREAT TO MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE FACE TODAY.
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH.
THERE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN LIMITS ON
SPEECH FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU CANNOT SHOW FIRE IN A
CROWDED THEATER THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE THIS BILL SIMPLY
STIPULATE THAT THE GROUP WILL BE
COMPRISED OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCATES AND FIRST AMENDMENT
SCHOLARS THAT UNDERSTAND.
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS AND
CONSTITUTIONALITY PROTECTED
SPEECH.
WE ALSO REALIZE THAT THIS IS A
VERY COMPLEX PROBLEM.
AND FREE SPEECH WHAT RIGHTS MUST
BE PROTECTED AS WE ALL KNOW.
NOW CONVENING A WORKING GROUP
WILL IN FACT BRING TOGETHER
PEOPLE WILL HAVE A VAST ARRAY OF
EXPERIENCE TO ADDRESS SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO FACE.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I'VE.
I THINK WE SHALL WITHOUT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
IT IS NOT A VOTE OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE KNOWS NINETEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY ONE AND
ONE NINETY TWO THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE SB.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AND ACT LIKE
ORGAN AND TISSUE DONATIONS.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
GALGIANI TO PRESENT S. B. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN THIS BILL WILL MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
DISCLOSURE LANGUAGE ON THE BACK
OF DRIVERS LICENSE.
REGARDING ORGAN DONATIONS THE
BILL WILL PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
TO CALIFORNIA DRIVERS REGARDING
THIS PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR OBERNOLTE SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM?
ONE NINETY FOUR THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE SB.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX CORKERY SENATE
BILL ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACTUALLY THE
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION.
MISTER CHAU YOU MAKE AN OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX A BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT TO
SEEK JUDICIAL REMEDY.
AND KISSES WERE STOLEN PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION IS USED
AND PUBLIC BUSINESS ENTITY
FILINGS.
SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX CLOSES THE
GAP IN STATE LAW IMPORTANT FOR
PROTECTING VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
THEFT.
WHILE STATE LAW ALLOWS FOR
VICTIMS TO SEEK JUDICIAL REMEDY
IN CASES WHERE FALSE LEAN FINING
FILINGS ARE MADE IN THEIR NAME.
STATE LAW DOES NOT SIMILARLY ARE
AUTHORIZED VICTIMS TO SEEK
JUDICIAL REMEDY WHEN STOLEN
PERSONAL IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
IS USED IN PUBLIC BUSINESS
ENTITY FILINGS.
BUT AUTHORIZED OUT BUSINESS
ENTITY FILINGS CREATE AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON VICTIMS OF
IDENTITY THEFT.
BY NOT ONLY OBLIGATING THEM TO
UNDERGO EXTRA PROCESS TO REVERSE
CHECKOUT DAMAGES RESULTING FROM
THE USE OF THEIR STOLEN
IDENTITY.
BUT BY CONTINUING TO MAKE
PUBLIC.
THE VICTIM'S PERSONAL
IDENTIFICATION.
SIR THIS OTHER HARMS HAVEN'T
FROM THE IDENTITY THEFT ARE
JUST.
THE BILL SIMPLY CREATES A SIMPLE
PROCESS FOR THESE VICTIMS TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY SEEK RECOURSE
RESTORED THE IDENTITY AND
PROCEED TO RECOVER FROM THE
INTRUSION INTO THEIR PRIVACY.
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY SIX
AUTHORIZES IDENTITY THEFT
VICTIMS TO OBTAIN A COURT ORDER
TO REMOVE PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION FROM PUBLIC.
BUSINESS ENTITY FILINGS.
THE BILL DIRECTS A JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO DEVELOP A FORM FOR
USE WHEN ISSUING SUCH AN ORDER.
BY AUTHOR I BY AUTHORIZING THIS
TYPE OF REMEDY S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX HELPS STOP FURTHER
HARM TO VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
THEFT WHERE THE STOLEN.
INFORMATION HAS BEEN USED IN
STATE BUSINESS ENTITY FILINGS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK VERY AYE
VOTE.
THINKING THIS SHALL SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE AYE SIXTY SEVEN
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SIX IS S. B.. TWELVE
A ONE COOPERATE CYCLE TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR STERN AND
ACTUALLY THE JUVENILES.
THIS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT S.
B. TWELVE EIGHTY ONE A BILL THAT
WILL IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT OF FIRE
A PROHIBITION SOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY LEGALLY PROHIBITED.
FROM OWNING OR POSSESSING A GUN
UNTIL AGE.
THIRTY UNDER EXISTING LAW PEOPLE
WHO COMMIT SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
OFFENSES AS JUVENILES CANNOT OWN
A GUN UNTIL THE AGE OF THIRTY
WITH THE RISING TREND IN
TERRIBLE CAN VIOLENCE.
THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN CALLING FOR
MORE COMMENTS COMMONSENSE GUN
POLICIES S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
SIMPLY SPECIFIES THAT JUVENILE
RECORDS CONTAINING FIRE ON
PROHIBITIONS ARE NOT DESTROYED.
UNTIL THAT PERSON TURNS.
THIRTY THREE THESE RECORDS
REMAIN SEALED AND THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPACT A PERSON'S HOUSING
JOBBER EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS IS NARROW IN SCOPE IN
ENFORCING GUN SAFETY LOS THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ZERO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY CAN WAS CREEL SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LOCAL
AROUND.
MEMBERS VOTE.
THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
LAWMAKERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
FIVE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE
FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SEVEN S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY SENATE BILL
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND ACTUALLY HOUSING
[inaudible]
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU I RISE TO PRESENT S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR SKINNER.
AS ENROLLMENT INCREASES IN UC'S
CS USE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE OF STUDENT HOUSING.
DENSITY BONUS LAW CAN HELP
FACILITATE AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING BUT CURRENTLY DOES NOT
ALLOW A 100% STUDENT PROJECTS.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN MAKE
STUDENT HOUSING ELIGIBLE 435%
DENSITY BONUS BY ALLOWING
DENSITY TO BE BASED ON ROOMS OR
BADS INSTEAD OF ON UNITS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES ALL
HOUSING ELIGIBLE WOULD BE A 100%
FOR STUDENTS AND THAT A MINIMUM
OF 20% OF THE UNITS BE RENTED AT
LOWER COST TO LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK LOVE THEY'RE ALL.
ON MEMBERS OF IT IS OUT OF A
LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TELL THE VOTE I SIXTY NINE
KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS [inaudible]
ONE NINETY EIGHT THROUGH. TO FOR
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
TWO OH FIVE THAT IS S. B.
[inaudible]
ELEVEN OH EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE ELEVEN NO EIGHT BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND
I PLAYED A MEDI CAL.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT YOU S. B. ELEVEN OO
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR.
HERNANDEZ IN JANUARY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ANNOUNCED A DRAMATIC
CHANGE IN POLICY BY ALLOWING
STATES TO CONDITION MEDICAID
COVERAGE ON WORK.
REQUIREMENTS THE UNDERLYING
THEORY BEHIND A WORK REQUIREMENT
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
WORKING CHOOSE TO BE UNEMPLOYED
BUT THERE ARE MAJOR FLAWS IN
THIS THINKING MOST MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES WHO CAN WORK
ALREADY DO SO.
IMPOSING WORK REQUIREMENTS WILL
ONLY CREATE BARRIERS TO
HEALTHCARE AND LEAD TO OVERLY
BURDENSOME PAPERWORK AND HIGHER
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
COVERING THE UNINSURED MAKING
MEDI CAL CONTINGENT ON WORK
REQUIREMENTS IS A STEP.
BACKWARDS S. B. ELEVEN WAIT
AUTHORIZES DE EIGHT CS TO SEEK
FEDERAL WAIVERS.
THAT ARE IN FURTHERANCE OF THE
GOAL OF MEDI CAL WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
CARE TO LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE COST.
OF HEALTH CARE.
THIS BILL PUTS CALIFORNIA ON
RECORD AS REJECTING MISGUIDED
ATTEMPTS TO TAKE MEDICAL
COVERAGE AWAY FROM THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE COLLEAGUES.
THE WHICH BONTA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
I'M.
IS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
HOWEVER I FIFTY DOES EIGHTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWO OF SIX IS S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
SENATE ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR PELL AND ACTUALLY THE
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
MR JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BELL WHICH WILL LIMIT
INVOLUNTARY PRETRIAL CONFINEMENT
FOR NO LONGER THAN TWO YEARS.
IF A PERSON IS DEEMED MENTALLY
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
THIS BILL ALSO UPDATES ARCHAIC
STANDARDS AND DEFINITIONS WITHIN
EXISTING LAW.
BY SHORTENING THE MAXIMUM
COMMITMENT PERIOD.
IS THE AVAILABILITY OF
PLACEMENTS AND RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES HOSPITALS
AND DEVELOP DEVELOPMENTALLY
CENTER CENTERS FOR ADDICTS
TREATMENT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
COMPETENT. TO STAND TRIAL
KEEPING PEOPLE IN US DEPARTMENT
OF STATE HOSPITALS BAD AND
LONGER THAN MEDICALLY NECESSARY
DOES NOT SERVE ANYONE'S
INTERESTS AND RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO
DEPARTMENT.
STATE HOSPITALS AND COUNTY JAIL
ADMINISTRATORS ULTIMATELY S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN INCREASES
THE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S UNDERGOING
COMPETENT EVALUATIONS BY
ENSURING NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL
THE NOT HELD. FOR AN UNNECESSARY
AMOUNT OF TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TELEVOTE.
I SWITCHED YOU KNOW.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY TWO THIS IS S. B..
TWO TWENTY ONE FILE ITEM WAY TO
S. B. TWO TWENTY ONE CORPOREAL.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY TO
AGRICULTURAL DISTRICTS
[inaudible]
MISTER TING.
THE IMAGE SPEAKER SP TWO TO ONE
BANDS GUN SHOWS AT THE COW
PALACE WHICH SIT ON THE BORDER
OF DALY CITY.
IN SAN FRANCISCO OF THE CAL
PALACE HOST ABOUT FIVE GUN SHOWS
A YEAR.
THE BILL WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO THAT ALL THE EXISTING
CONTRACTS WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
FOR FILLED.
UP ALL THE GOVERNING BODIES
WITHIN --
SAN FRANCISCO DALY CITY AS WELL
AS SAN MATEO COUNTY HAVE ALL
CALLED ON THE COW PALACE TO BAN.
GUN SHOWS UNFORTUNATELY THE COW
PALACE IS GOVERNED AS A STATE
ENTITY SO THEREFORE WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
DISTRICT BILL.
OUR DISTRICT TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALL BEEN VERY
MUCH UNITED IN ASKING THAT THE
COW PALACE NO LONGER HAVE ANY
GUN SHOWS --
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS TANK YES VISIBLE
AT THIS YEAR RECOGNIZE THINK
MISTER SPEAKER I HAVE A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHORED BY ME.
WITHOUT OBJECTION --
IS THERE.
IS THERE A SAFETY CONCERN --
RELATING TO THIS GUN SHOW WHERE
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
SHOOTINGS THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
NUMBER YOU KNOW.
WHAT IS THERE SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED AT THESE GUN SHOWS THAT
HAS BEEN A PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS [inaudible]
SO SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURE DEBATE MISTER TAKE
YOU MAY ADDRESS THAT I'M SORRY.
MISTAKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS A QUESTION NOW
[inaudible]
STING -- AT
THAT THIS POINT THE COMMUNITIES
DIRECTLY SURROUNDING THE CAL
PALACE WHICH ARE BOTH SAN
FRANCISCO DALY CITY HAVE.
UNANIMOUSLY UNIFORMLY ASK FOR
THE CAL PALACE NOT TO SHOW NOT
NOT TO HAVE --
THESE GUN SHOWS THAT AT THIS
POINT I HAVEN'T BEEN MADE AWARE
OF ANY.
SPECIFIC INCIDENTS BUT THERE IS
A FEELING WITH THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY THAT THERE ARE TOO
MANY GUNS ARE IN THE SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOOD SO THEY THEY
REALLY.
ARE FROM MATTER OF FARM.
POLICY REALLY DON'T WANT THE COW
PALACE TO BE HAVING ANY MORE
CONSCIOUS [inaudible]
THIS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU I AM ON MY OWN TIME
AND WHAT'S GOING ON TO MAKE
FRIENDS TODAY --
I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE AND
THEN IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH THERE
HASN'T NECESSARILY BEEN ANY.
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES WITH THIS
GUN SHOW BEING HELD BUT MORE
THAT -- IT'S
A IT'S IT'S A FEELING OF THEIR
FOLKS WERE AND YOU JUST DON'T
WANT THEM THERE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN THERE ARE OTHER
EVENTS GOING ON IN SOME OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS IN CITIES WHERE
THEY DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE
THOSE EVENTS --
HOWEVER IT'S IT'S THEIR RIGHT --
TO EXERCISE WHETHER IT'S AT A
GUN SHOW OR SOME OTHER TYPE OF
ON THE VENT WITH.
WITH WITH WHICH ONE DISAGREES SO
GIVEN THAT THERE IS NO SAFETY
CONCERN.
WITH THE GUN SHOW BEING HELD AT
THE COW PALACE --
I WOULD URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
--
FOR FOR THEM TO HAVE THIS SHOW
AND UNTIL THERE'S A SOME SORT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY MATTER AT HAND --
ALLOW THE SHOW TO CONTINUE TO GO
ON A FAMOUS ONE AS MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I REGRETFULLY HAVE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB --
TWO TO ONE THIS BILL AND ITS
PROHIBITION.
WILL NOT ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY
AS THE CURRENT LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES ALL FIREARM
TRANSACTIONS AT THE COW PALACE
OR ANY OTHER.
GUN SHOW LOCATION IN CALIFORNIA
TO MEET THE SAME STRINGENT
STANDARDS AS REQUIRED IN THE
DEALER STORE.
INDEED WHEREVER A FIREARMS
TRANSACTION COMMENCES STATE LAW
MANDATES A WAITING PERIOD
REINFORCED IN THE FIREARM
REMAIN.
IN THE POSSESSION OF THE
TRANSACTING DEALER UNTIL THAT
PERIOD ENDS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE HAS COMPLETED THE
REQUIRED BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT THE
CAL POLICY IS A DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION.
WHICH RECEIVES MINIMAL SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE BUDGET.
IT LIKE OTHER DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS
INCLUDING IN MY DISTRICT THAT
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS.
IN CALIFORNIA ARE EXPECTED TO
GENERATE THEIR OWN REVENUES FROM
TRADE SHOWS LIVESTOCK AUCTIONS
CONCERTS AT CENTER.
PROHIBITING GUNS JONES AT THE
COW PALACE NOT ONLY ELIMINATES A
LEGAL VENUE FOR THE SALE OF
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION.
UNDER THE WATCHFUL EYE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL AND IN
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW.
BUT IT ALSO HARMS THE FINANCIAL
SITUATION OF THE VENUE.
I URGE YOU CAN TO CONSIDER THIS
ISSUE AND THOUGHT SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO SAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SOUTHERN SAN
MATEO COUNTY --
THAT I HOPE WE DON'T WAIT UNTIL
THERE'S A SAFETY.
ARE IF YOU WERE INCIDENT BEFORE
WE TAKE PROACTIVE MEASURES AND
IF THIS OR AYE FACILITY UNDER
LOCAL CONTROL OF THIS WE ARE
FACILITY THAT WAS.
CONTROLLED BY THE COUNTY THE
COUNTY WOULD HAVE EVERY RIGHT
SIDE TO PROHIBIT A GUN SHOW FROM
OCCURRING THERE OF THIS HAPPENS
TO BE FACILITY THAT'S CONTROLLED
BY THE STATE WHICH IS WHY --
WE HAVE THE BILL IN FRONT OF US
BUT I CAN.
ASSURE YOU HAVING REPRESENT
BEING THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR A
PART OF THIS COMMUNITY THAT THEY
DON'T FEEL SAFE HAVING DONE
SHOWS.
IN THIS FACILITY.
O. AND AND SO I HOPE THAT WE
DON'T WAIT UNTIL THERE'S AN
INCIDENT IN PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE
LOST.
BEFORE WE LISTEN TO THE
COMMUNITY --
AND THAT BECAUSE THIS IS
CONTROLLED BY THE STATE --
TAKE ACTION IN THAT'S WITH
THAT'S ALIGNED WITH THE WISHES
OF THE COMMUNITY TO KEEP THEIR
COMMUNITIES SAFER THANK YOU.
THANK WAS BERMAN MISTER HARPER
HERE RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A QUESTION
HERE OF WHETHER THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS EVEN ALLOWING
TRANSACTIONS TO BE ABLE HAPPEN
WITHIN THEIR SPACE.
I WAS REVIEWING AN ARTICLE THE
CENSUS CHO CHRONICLE ENTITLED
SAN FRANCISCO'S LONE GUN STORE
CAN RE OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
SO THE QUESTION IS.
HOW MANY PLACES CAN A PERSON
EVEN BUY A FIREARM WITH IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
OR WITHIN THE LOCAL AREA? TO ME
THIS SEEMS TO BE A QUESTION OF
ACCESS. TO PEOPLE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND THE STATE
IS GOING TO SHUT DOWN ONE OF THE
LAST OR PERHAPS THE LAST PLACE.
TO BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE A FIREARM
THAT SEEMS TO BE AND
CONTRADICTORY TO THEIR SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS IN THE LOCAL
AREA EVEN IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
EVEN.
IN THE BAY AREA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM FOR THE
BODY MISTER TAKING MAKE CLOSE.
THANK IT SPEAKER ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN WE SEE THIS ISSUE IS VERY
MUCH A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE WE
HAVE SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOODS
DIRECTLY ADJACENT TO THE CAL
PALACE WHICH TO HAVE A HISTORY
OF GUN VIOLENCE --
WE'VE SEEN THIS FROM A SAN
FRANCISCO AND A SAN MATEO COUNTY
POINT OF VIEW TO VERY MUCH NOT
WANT THESE GUN SHOWS TO EXIST WE
SEE THIS VERY MUCH AS A LOCAL
DISTRICT ISSUE AS WELL THOUGH
SAFETY ISSUE.
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE FOR THIS JUST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CHIANG AND
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THOSE ARE TO ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL A VOTE EYES.
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY FOUR THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BACK IN FILE ORDER MEMBERS WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM.
TWO OH SEVEN S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN COOPERATE SETTLED SWELLED
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEASURE
THIS MEASURE PUTS INTO STATE LAW
THE CORRECT MEDICAL NECESSITY
STANDARD FOR CHILDREN ENROLLED
IN MEDICARE HOW.
MEASURE SPONSORED BY THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN THE
NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM AND
HAS ENJOYED.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE.
THEY'D ACT WOULD.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
UNDESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALIBAN AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO AWAIT
INTO A NINE THAT MOVES US TO
FILE ITEM TO TEN S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE CORKERY.
SENEGAL THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND OTHERS AND
I FIND HEALTH INSURANCE.
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAKE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INSURANCE LAWS IN ORDER TO
ENSURE COMPREHENSIVE ACA
COVERAGE. FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
WITHOUT EMPLOYEES COVER TO AN
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN OR
ANOTHER OR ANY OTHER ARRANGEMENT
THE BILL REQUIRES A STATUS OF
EACH DISTINCT MEMBER OF AN
ASSOCIATION DETERMINE WHETHER.
THE MEMBERS ASSOCIATION COVER
[inaudible]
A GROUP OR LARGE GROUP HEALTH
COVERAGE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NEED ACT WOULD SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TOWN ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN NO SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE TO PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS.
TO ELEVEN AND TO TWELVE WE ARE
FILE ONTO THIRTEEN SP TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE CAR FOR FREE.
SENATE THAT'S WILD EIGHTY THREE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN ATHLETE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MISTER BERMAN EMAIL ME.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT S.
B. TWELVE EIGHTY THREE WHICH
WOULD AUTHORIZE TYPE SEVENTY
FIVE A BREW PUB RESTAURANT
LICENSEES. TO DONATE TO
NONPROFITS AND SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS FOR OFF SITE
CONSUMPTION UNDER LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF MANY MEETINGS WITH
MEMBERS AND STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
INDUSTRY.
AND WAS PULLED FROM CONSENT ONLY
TO DISCUSS FURTHER TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WHICH WERE NEVER
INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
ULTIMATELY S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE IS AIMED AT MEETING
CONSUMER DEMAND AND SUPPORTING
CRAFT BREWERIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHICH CONTRIBUTE OVER
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND CREATE MORE THAN FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND JOBS STATEWIDE THINK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
HOMEOWNERS VOTE SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I
SIX NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
IT WAS ONE OF PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEMS TO FOURTEEN AND
TWO FIFTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE AND TO SIXTEEN WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM.
TO SEVENTEEN S. B.. EIGHT
NINETEEN COOPERATE SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINETEEN BY SENATOR HELL
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
ENERGY.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
SB EIGHT NINETEEN BAD.
PROTECTS CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS
FROM UTILITIES NEGLIGENT
BEHAVIOR AT THIS DOES ASSEMBLY
BY CODIFY EXISTING P. YOU SEE
PRACTICES MANDATING THAT FINES
PENALTIES IN EXPENSES RESULTING
FROM UNREASONABLE BEHAVIOR.
ARE NOT RECOVERABLE IN RATES --
THIS HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SHE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE ASSES WE ARE
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS [inaudible]
TO EIGHTEEN THROUGH [inaudible]
TWO THIRTY WHERE FILE ITEM.
TO THIRTY ONE S. B. [inaudible]
NINE EIGHTY ONE THIS IS.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE S. B..
NINE EIGHTY ONE CLARK OR RATE.
SAMPLE NINE EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY THE
BUSINESS.
IS RUBIO YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL.
NINETY TWO ONE CURRENT LAW
SPECIFIES THAT WHEN THE CUSTOMER
PURCHASES A WATER TREATMENT
SYSTEM FOR THEIR HOME AND THEY
SIGNED A CONTRACT WITH THE
SELLER.
NO WATER TREATMENT TREATMENT
DEVICE OR MATERIAL MAY BE
DELIVERED AND NO SERVICES MAY BE
PERFORMED UNTIL THE END OF A
THREE DAY RIGHT TO RESEND PERIOD
EXPIRES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF WATER TREATMENT
DEVICES.
DURING THAT THREE DAY RIGHT TO
RESCIND PERIOD ONLY WHEN
REQUESTED BY THE PURCHASER.
THIS CHANGE CREATES PARITY IN
THE APPLICATION OF THE LAW FOR
WATER TREATMENT COMPANIES AND
SIMILAR DOOR TO DOOR SALES
INDUSTRIES LICENSE BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
FURTHER THIS BILL STRENGTHENS
EXISTING LAW REQUIRING THE
SELLER OF THE PRODUCT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL COSTS IN
REMOVING THE INSTALLED WATER
TREATMENT DEVICE.
WITHIN TWENTY DAYS IF COUNSELED
BY THE CUSTOMER AND THE SELLER
MUST ALSO RESTORE THE PREMISES
TO ITS ORIGINAL CONDITION.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEE DISCUSSION DEBATE THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AND I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE
WE ARE MOVING BACK.
FILE ORDER TO ITEM TO FOURTEEN
S. B. ELEVEN TEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD ACTUALLY TO
ENERGY THANK YOU AS A MEMBER
DALY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE MEN SPEAKER MEMBERS --
SP ONE TEN IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE THAT PROTECTS PUBLIC
UTILITY RATEPAYERS.
SUMMIT IS A PAL MISS UP.
SOME MUNICIPAL UTILITIES BILL
POWER PLANTS IN DIRECT RESPONSE
TO THE ENERGY CRISIS AND ARE
STILL PAYING OFF THEIR BONTA
THIS BILL WILL RESOLVE THE DEBT
WITHOUT SHIFTING.
IT ON A RATE PAYERS OR
THREATENING ESSENTIAL CITY
SERVICES.
THIS WILL SAVE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
REQUIRE ONLY MINIMAL WORK OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING THE FACT AND FILE ORDER.
TO ITEM TWO THIRTY THREE SB
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR HERNANDEZ AND ACT ON A
PUBLIC HEALTH.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA PASS
TEMPORARILY ON ITEM.
TO THIRTY THREE WE ARE GOING
BACK TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEDI SPEAKER I RISE IN
TO PRESENT S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO LET'S LSP
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO IS ONE SMALL
BUT IMPORTANT PIECE OF
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
RESPONSE TO RECENT CASES OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS BEING
DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITALS AND
LEFT AT BUS STOPS OR SHELTERS
THAT ARE UNABLE TO SERVE THEM.
SOMETIMES WEARING ONLY A
HOSPITAL GOWN WITH NO WHERE TO
GO.
THIS BILL REFLECTS THE NEED FOR
HAAS I'M SORRY SOME MEMBER WOULD
I BEG YOUR PARDON WE'RE GOING TO
BE PASSING TEMPORARILY ON THIS
ITEM
.
OKAY WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM TWO
THIRTY SEVEN SP TWO SEVENTY FOR
US MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR GLAZER IN ATLANTA
TAXATION DECLARE THEIR NC THERE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
YOU THINK YOU'RE SOME MEMBER
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SP
TWO SEVENTY FOUR AS A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP PROVIDE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO FTP TO ESTABLISH A
PROCESS FOR TAXPAYERS. TO REPORT
AND PAY CALIFORNIA TAXES
CONFORMING TO THE NEW FEDERAL
RULES PERTAINING TO PARTNERSHIP
AUDIT ADJUSTMENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGE THE
WAY ADJUSTMENTS FROM AUDITS OF
PARTNERSHIPS ARE SET BY THE IRS.
THESE NEW FEDERAL RULES ATTEMPT
TO CENTRALIZE PARTNERSHIP AUDIT
AND ADJUSTMENTS AND ALLOW THE
PARTNERSHIP ALLOCATED SHARE OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS AND ANY TAX
LIABILITY TO THE INDIVIDUAL
PARTNERS.
THESE THE FEDERAL RULES ARE
MANDATORY BEGINNING WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TAXABLE YEAR
IN COLLABORATION WITH FTP CAO
TAX IN SEVERAL NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS LANGUAGE PRESENT
IN THE BILL AUTHORIZING AT TV TO
COLLECT FROM PARTNERSHIPS OR
OTHER INDIVIDUAL PARTNERS ANY
INCREASE.
STATE TAX LIABILITY RESULTING
FROM FEDERAL AUDITS OF
PARTNERSHIP.
IS ENJOYED UNIT UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN [inaudible]
QUESTION I SOME MEMBER BRO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM CHAIR I
JUST RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CHAIR OF THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE.
BUT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THIS
JOINT EFFORT LED AND SUPPORTED
BY CAL TAX FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND SEVERAL TAX ORGANIZATIONS
IT'S A GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVOKE PROMOTE
UNIFORMITY WITHIN OUR TAX LAWS.
WHILE EASING COMPLIANCE AND
REDUCING COSTS TO TAXPAYERS ON A
MULTI STATE ISSUE THANK YOU
NEVER CASH AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK.
MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MOVE.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO THIRTY EIGHT
SP THREE NINETY NINE BOTTOM FOR
CLUES READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND I PLAN TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOWS
AREA AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER S. B.
THREE NINETY NINE WILL
ELIMINATE.
SIGNIFICANT ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS
IMPOSED BY HEALTH PLANS THAT
PREVENT CALIFORNIA FAMILIES FROM
ACCESSING EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM EARLY
INTERVENTION BY THE APPROPRIATE
FORM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
TREATMENT HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING THE
EFFECTS OF AUTISM ON CHILDREN S.
B..
NINE FORTY SIX THE STEINBERG
SENATOR FORMER SENATOR
STEINBERG'S BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REQUIRED HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR AUTISM.
S. B. THREE NINETY NINE AS A
FOLLOW UP TO CORRECT DRAFTING
ERRORS IN S. B. NINE FORTY SIX
IN ORDER TO EXPAND THE TYPES OF
SERVICES AND PROVIDERS INCLUDED
IN THE CURRENT AUTISM INSURANCE
MANDATE.
I'D THIS WILL ENSURE THAT EVERY
PERSON WITH AUTISM HAS HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR THEIR MEDICALLY
PRESCRIBED TREATMENT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEADOW CREEK MAY OPEN
THE ROLE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY SIX NO EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS.
TO THIRTY NINE THROUGH TO FORTY
THREE PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM TWO FORTY FOUR S.. THIRTY
FOUR MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE PLANS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MERCER TO
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I AM
PLEASED.
AND PROUD TO PRESENT SP EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR JACKSON.
SENATE JACKSON I'VE BEEN BEEN
WORKING TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR EFFORTS TO RE OPEN
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA.
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WILL
PROHIBIT THE ISSUANCE OF ANY NEW
LEASE AUTHORIZING NEW
CONSTRUCTION OF OIL AND GAS
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
WITHIN STATE WATERS ASSOCIATED
WITH ANY LEASES ISSUED AFTER
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN.
AND I LIKE TO CLARIFY BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
OUT THERE BUT LIKE TO CLARIFY
THE RECENT AMENDMENT BY AS
CENTER JACKSON SP.
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WELD REMOVE
PROHIBITIONS ON AMENDMENTS TO
EXISTING LEASES SO IN OTHER
WORDS.
THE SP EIGHT THIRTY FALL WILL
NOT AFFECT EXISTING LEASES.
WE ALL I'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT HOW
THERE'S OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
STATEWIDE SUPPORT. TO OPPOSE
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA.
RECENT POLLS SHOWING THAT 69% OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE OPPOSED TO
ANY NEW OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SUPPORTED BY
SCO YOU SIERRA CLUB THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ILLEGAL
WOMEN VOTERS HOST OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION THE
CITIES.
PLAYS FIGHT BACK PROTECT OUR AND
SHARE OUR COSTA ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO THRIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM HER PLEASE OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
SOME MEMBERS WHO CHEAT CALL
PLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
MOVES THE CALL.
ITEM TWO FORTY FIVE PASS AND
RETAIN A MOVING TO ITEM TWO
FORTY SIX S. B. EIGHT NINETY SIX
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE
THE ARSON.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'M SPEAKER.
SP EIGHT NINETY SIX WILL EXTEND
THE SUNSET DATE ON THE STATE'S
AGGRAVATED ARSON STATUTES UNTIL
JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WILL ALSO
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY DAMAGE FROM SEVEN
MILLION TO A POINT THREE
MILLION.
TO ADJUST FOR INFLATION THIS
PENALTY IS RESERVED FOR THE
WORST OF THE WORST.
ARSONISTS TO EXHIBIT SPECIFIC
INTENT TO INFLICT DAMAGE TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND PRESENT A
CONTINUING THREAT TO SOCIETY.
STATURE HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
SUBJECT TO A SUNSET DATE IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THE LEGISLATION
TO JUST TO ADJUST.
THE DAMAGE LAS FACTOR FOR
INFLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I WROTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE NOT A QUICK EMAIL FOR THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWO FORTY SEVEN S. B. NINE
THIRTY THREE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE ON NINE THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY INDIVIDUAL PERFORMING
ARTS EDUCATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE
ESTABLISHES THE ARTS FOR EVERY
STUDENT ACT.
WHICH IS INTENDED TO CLOSE THE
GAP IN ACCESS TO VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATION FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THE ACT CREATES AN INCENTIVE
GRANT TO HELP SCHOOLS BUILD UPON
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO EXPAND ARTS
EDUCATION.
ACCESS AND CREATE NEW PROGRAMS.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS OUR STATE.
ARTS EDUCATION HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE CRITICAL THINKING AND
PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS.
THE CELTIC CROSS CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORTS THE
VEHICLE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND
SHORTED WORKS I'VE USED IT
MYSELF MANY TIMES MY OWN
CLASSROOM IT CONNECTS KIDS TO
THEIR LEARNING.
BY PASSING S. B. NINE THIRTY
THREE WE CAN BRING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR TO
EDUCATION TO STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK MAY OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS TO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS FORTY EIGHT AND FORTY NINE
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEMS TO FIFTY PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FIFTY ONE S.
B. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU
pYOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO RESENT S. B. NINE SEVEN EIGHT
ON HAVE WE HAVE A CENTER
BRADFORD WHICH WILL REQUIRE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TO POST A POLICIES.
AND PROCEDURES ONLINE THIS IS
ALREADY PRACTICE OF MORE THAN
THIRTY AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
AS AN AGENCY POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE ALREADY PUBLIC
RECORDS THIS TRANSPARENCY WILL
HELP TO BUILD TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
MAKING THESE RECORDS AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC THAT BOTH SMART
AND WRITING TO DO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FREE AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DOES DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FIFTY TWO S.
B. NINE EIGHTY NINE QUIRK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI ACTUALLY THE
HIGHWAYS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
A THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHTY NINE SP NINE EIGHTY NINE
WOULD AUTHORIZED CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. TO
RELINQUISH A SPECIAL AS SPECIFIC
PORTION OF STATE ROUTE EIGHTY
FOUR TO THE CITY OF FREMONT.
THE BILL IS THE RESULT OF OVER A
DECADE OF CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
THE CITY FREMONT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
S. B. NINE EIGHTY YET NINE WILL
DELIVER MUCH NEEDED AND LONG
AWAITED TRANSPORTATION.
IMPROVEMENTS TO ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND PROVIDE THE STATE WITH LONG
TERM ANNUAL SAVINGS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. NINE O'CLOCK YOU MAY CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FIFTY THREE
SB TEN OH FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ CYNICAL TEN OF FIVE
BY SENATOR ATKINS AND OTHERS AND
I PLAN TO CRIME VICTIMS MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'M HERE TODAY 2% S. B.. TEN OH
FIVE THAT A BILL OF ALLOW
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND OTHER VIOLENT CRIMES TO USE
RELOCATION FUNDS PROVIDED.
BY THE VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD
TO PAY EXPENSES RELATED TO
HOUSING AN ANIMAL COMPANION SUCH
AS PET DEPOSITS AND PET RENT.
IN CALIFORNIA APPROXIMATELY 40%
OF WOMEN EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE IN
THEIR LIFETIMES. FOR THOSE THAT
OWN A PET CONCERN OVER THEIR
PATH SAFETY PLAYS A MAJOR ROLE
IN THE DECISION MAKING.
SADLY HALF A DOZEN OF STUDIES
HAVE REPORTED THAT WOMEN IN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS.
OFTEN POSTPONED THEIR LEAVING
THE RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE OF
CONCERN FOR THEIR PETS WELFARE.
CALIFORNIA'S VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD PROVIDES FINANCIAL RELIEF
FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND PROVIDES TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE RELOCATION.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFY THAT THESE FUNDS COULD
BE USED TO ASSIST VICTIMS WITH
PAT RENT OR PATH DEPOSITS.
THEY ME EVEN A S. B. CHANNEL
FIVE WILL HELP THOSE VICTIMS
LEAVE THEIR ABUSIVE ENVIRONMENT
BY REDUCING THE FINANCIAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS GAPING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SENATE A ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BE TUNNEL [inaudible]
FIVE THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
OF MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS TO FIFTY FOUR TO FIFTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX S. B. TEN
NINETEEN ABOUT IN HER PLEASE
READ.
CYCLE TEN NINETEEN BY SENATOR
BALLOT OTHERS IN ATLANTA YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SP TEN NINETEEN CREATES
PARITY.
IN THE ALLOCATION OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION FUNDS COME ONLY
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS TRIAGE
TRIAGE FUNDS.
AND POLLSTERS MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND
REGIONAL MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL ALLOCATES
AT LEAST HALF OF THE TRIAGE
GRANT FUNDS. FOR SERVICES
TARGETED TO YOUTH AND CREATES
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
OPERATING IN THE COUNT T.
NETWORK.
CURRENTLY CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING FOR YOUTH CENTRIC
PROGRAMS RECEIVED JUST OVER 15%.
OF THE GRANT FUNDS PREVIOUSLY
AWARDED WITH THE REMAINING 85%
BE IN BEING ALLOCATED TO ADULTS.
WE MUST ENSURE CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS ARE GIVEN EQUAL
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT DAHLE
PROGRAMS RECEIVE.
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS OFFERS STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND EXTENDED
NETWORK OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT ARE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE.
THIS BILL ENSURES COLLABORATION
WITH BOTH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE GRANTS ARE
ADMINISTERED WITH BOTH
PERSPECTIVES THAN MINE.
S. B. TEN NINETEEN HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND IS SUPPORTED BY
NUMEROUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
MENTAL HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. B..
TEN NINETEEN THANK YOU SEEING
THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO FIFTY SEVEN
SP.
TEN TWENTY ONE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR WIENER AND
OTHERS ARE LIKELY TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH EXTENDS AND
EXPANDS UPON CRITICAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS BILL
MAINTAINS A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR CAP ON CO PAYS FOR A
MONTH'S SUPPLY OF A SINGLE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
BEFORE THESE PROTECTIONS WERE
ACTED CONSUMERS WITH INSURANCE
WERE FREQUENTLY SUBJECT TO HUGE
COPAYS FOR LIFESAVING
MEDICATION.
FOR EXAMPLE ALMOST ALL HIV DRUGS
ARE MOVED ON TO SO CALLED
SPECIALTY TEARS AND HIV POSITIVE
CALIFORNIANS WERE ASKED TO PAY
MONTHLY COPAYS OF EIGHT HUNDRED
TO TWELVE HUNDRED PER MONTH PER
PRESCRIPTION.
S. B. TEN TWENTY ONE ALSO RETAIN
STANDARDS GOVERNING WHICH DRUGS
CAN BE PLACED ON WHICH TO YEAR
OF AN INSURER'S FORMULA.
A GUARANTEES THAT ALL OF THE
DRUGS FOR A SINGLE CONDITION
SUCH AS MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
CANNOT BE PLACED ON THE HIGHEST
MOST EXPENSIVE TIER.
FINALLY THE BILL ENSURES THAT
PEOPLE WITH INSURANCE HAVE
ACCESS TO A SINGLE TABLET PROP
REGIMEN.
A ONCE A DAY PILL THAT VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATES THE RISK OF HIV
INFECTION.
S. B. TEN TWENTY ONE WILL HAVE
MINIMAL IMPACT ON PREMIUMS AND
WILL CHAIR THE CALIFORNIANS
LIVES WILL NOT BE PUT AT REST BY
HIGH DRUG COSTS AS THEY WERE IN
THE NOT TOO DISTANT PAST.
THIS MEASURE WILL EXTEND PROVING
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND HELP
CONTROL PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS
IT HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO VOTES
IN THE ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS TO FIFTY EIGHT THROUGH TWO
SIXTY PASS AND RETAIN ITEM TO
SIXTY ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM TWO SIXTY TWO S.
B. ELEVEN OH FOR MEDICAL PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NO FOR BY
SENATOR ROTH AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE SAFETY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THE
MAN SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN ZERO FOUR
WHICH REQUIRES SCHOOLS PROVIDE
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS WITH
CRITICAL INFORMATION.
ON THE INDICATORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE HAVE MORE REPORTED CASES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
WELL THIS LEGISLATORS PASSED
SEVERAL IMPORTANT BILLS OVER THE
YEARS REQUIRED TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS. TO BE PROVIDED
INFORMATION RELATED TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WE HAVE FAILED TO
INCLUDE PARENTS AND GUARDIANS IN
THE TRAFFICKING PREVENTION
DISCUSSION.
S. B. ELEVEN OO FOR ROOF CAR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS OF MILAN
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO HELP
THEM IDENTIFY SIGNS THAT THEIR
CHILD.
IS BEING GROOMED FOR
TRAFFICKING.
BY PASSING US BELOW FOR WE CAN
WRITE PARENTS OR GUARDIANS THE
TOOLS THEY NEED. TO PROTECT OUR
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
I ASK FOR A NIGHT.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ITEM TWO SIXTY
THREE SB ELEVEN OH SIX MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE BILL OF
THE NO SIX BY SENATOR HELL AND
ACTUALLY TO CRIMES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS.
SP ELEVEN OH SIX EXTENDS THE
SUNSET DATE TO THE TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOU PILOT PROJECT.
WHICH HELPS IMPROVE OUTCOMES OF
YOUNG ADULTS.
COME INTO CONTACT WITH THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ADDS VENTURA
COUNTY.
THE PILOT PROGRAM PROVIDES THESE
YOUNG ADULTS ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH.
THE PATIENT TRAINING AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARRIVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A RECORD REQUEST
TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR S.
B. ELEVEN NINETEEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINETEEN BY SENATOR PELL AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEADOW SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES S. B. ELEVEN NINETEEN
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
REQUIREMENTS WITHIN THE LOW
CARBON TRANSIT OPERATIONS
PROGRAM.
SB ELEVEN NINETEEN WILL ALLOW
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO INVEST
PROGRAM FUNDING ACROSS THREE
ADDITIONAL AREAS INCOME BLIND IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS.
IN ORDER TO FURTHER BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY MANY
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND IS RECEIVED AND NO NO
VOTES.
THIS BILL AIMS TO PROVIDE
MOBILITY OPTIONS TO THOSE MOST
IN NEED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON IT S. B.. ELEVEN
NINETEEN ELEVEN A LOT
[inaudible] ELEVEN NINETEEN
THIS.
ONE I THINK YOU --
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT I'D ON SB.
ELEVEN NINETEEN BOTTOM QUIRK YOU
MAY CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT OF ITEM TWO SIXTY
FIVE S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS DAM PRESENTING SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LEYVA.
SP ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR INSURERS
ARE RETIREES COULD NOT BE FORCED
TO PAY BACK COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN
RETIREMENT BENEFITS DUE TO
EMPLOYER ERRORS OR REPORTING IN%
ACCOUNTING.
THIS MEASURES OF RESPONSE TO
INSTANCES IN WHICH THE
COMPENSATION INFORMATION OF
RETIRED EMPLOYEES WAS
MISCALCULATED OR INCORRECTLY
REPORTED BY CALPERS TO CALPERS
BY THEIR EMPLOYERS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW RETIREES ARE
FORCED TO PAY BACK THE OVERPAID
AMOUNT OR EVEN SUFFER REDUCTIONS
IN FUTURE PAYMENTS THIS IS A
PROBLEMATIC ISSUE SINCE RETIREES
OFTEN RELY ON FIXED INCOMES AND
PLAN FOR THE RETIREMENT.
BASED ON THAT INCOME AMOUNT
FORTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE RETIREES
WITH PEACE OF MIND THAT THEY
WILL NOT BE FORCED TO SUFFER
REDUCTIONS TO THEIR PENSION
PAYMENTS BECAUSE OF AN
ACCOUNTING ERROR OR REPORTING
AIR BY THEIR EMPLOYERS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MEADOW PARK WAS OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ANDTALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWO SIXTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO SIXTY SEVEN
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO THE
LOS ANGELES RIVER A TRIBUTARY TO
CLAIM THAT WOULD SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REDUCE YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
HERE TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE
CLEAN UP MEASURE THAT WILL ADD
THE ROYAL SECCO TRIBUTARY TO THE
UPPER.
LOS ANGELES RIVER AND
TRIBUTARIES WORKING GROUP THE
BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES THE WORKING
GROUP TO INCLUDE MEMBERS WITHIN
THE ROYAL SECCO.
TRIBUTARY FROM THE CITIES OF
LOCKING OUT OF FLINTRIDGE
PASADENA AND SOUTH PASADENA.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL EXTEND
THE DEADLINE FOR THE REQUIRED
REPORT ON THE RIVER RANGERS
PROGRAM TO MARCH.
TWENTY NINETEEN S. BE ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS AND I YOU NOW.
AND HAS UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS REASON I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THE ITEM PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWO SIXTY
EIGHT SB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR DODD AND
ACT [inaudible]
EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU RECOGNIZE
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST YEAR
SENATOR DODD INTRODUCED SENATE
BILL.
THREE THREE FOUR WHICH PASSED
THE LEGISLATURE NOW TO ME
UNANIMOUSLY WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT EXTENDED ENHANCED
INDUSTRIAL DELUDE DISABILITY
LEAVE TO CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS
INJURED ON THE JOB INCLUDING.
DURING TRAINING SB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR IS A CLEAN ABOUT TO THAT
LEGISLATION.
THIS BILL THAT EXTENDS ANY
SALARY INCREASES GIVEN TO ACTIVE
FIREFIGHTERS TO THOSE ON ENHANCE
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY.
SOME EXTENSIONS ALREADY APPLIED
A LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL
POLICE AND THE CALIFORNIA OUR
PATROL AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR HAS
OPPOSITION AND SPONSORED BY CAL
FIRE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT THAT YOU
WANT RESPECTFULLY OUT FOR OUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE FOOD OF
OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THAT A PERKYOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
TO TWENTY TWO SP TWELVE NINETY
THREE MADAM CLERK CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
CLINICAL TWELVE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SP
TWELVE NINE THREE SEEKS TO
FURTHER MATCH THE SPIRIT AND
INTENT OF AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
ALSO BY MR LARA BY ALLOWING THE
STATE AUDITOR TO EXAMINE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DURING THE COURSE OF
THEIR HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM TO
DETERMINE IF THERE ANY.
AREAS THAT ARE AT RISK OF FRAUD
WASTE OR MISMANAGEMENT.
THIS PROGRAM ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY PROBLEM
AREAS AND WORK TO FIX THESE
PROBLEMS BEFORE REQUIRING A FULL
AUDIT.
SINCE CREATION OF THIS PROGRAM
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S CRACKED OF GUIDANCE
PROGRAM AVOIDING PAST MISTAKES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BUT A QUICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MOVING NOW BACK AND FILE ORDER
TO ITEM TWO SEVENTY ONE SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SENATE ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO ACTUALLY
FIREARMS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MANY
SPEAKER THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
BUT IMPORTANT BILL.
AND WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO DO
IS BRING PARITY THE HANDGUN LAW
BILL.
ANY QUIP THAT TO WHAT WE NOW DO
WITH LONG WHAT WHAT WE SHOULD DO
WITH LONG GUNS WHICH IS THAT
NOBODY SHOULD BY.
MORE THAN ONE LONG GUN PER
THIRTY DAYS NOW THERE ARE SOME
EXEMPTIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
STATE LOCAL CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES.
LICENSE PRIVATE SECURITY
COMPANIES.
PRIVATE PARTY TRANSACTIONS
[inaudible]
I AND FIREARMS DEALERS AMONG
OTHERS IS RESPONSIBLE BILL.
AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SO.
HERE YOU GO WITH ANOTHER GUN
CONTROL BILL FROM MY FRIEND
ACROSS THE AISLE OVER THERE --
IF YOU LOOK AT THE STATISTICS Y.
GUESS FIRST CAN I ASK A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR BEFORE CONTINUE
WITH MY COMMENTS [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IS IT DO HOUSE OF DATA OR
STATISTIC STATISTICS TO SHOW
THAT --
THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE IN
CRIME --
USING RIFLES OR OR LONG GUNS.
I WILL ALLOW HIM TO REDRESS THIS
NOW OR AS CLOSE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO INTERJECT THAT
NOW YOU'LL ADDRESS IT AND IS
CLOSE THAT AS HIS* HIS --
YOU WANT TO DO IT IN YOUR
CLOTHES HE DOESN'T ANSWER IT
NOW.
OKAY WHAT'S UNFORTUNATE OKAY SO
--
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL THERE IS NO
DATA TO SUGGEST THAT IF THERE
HAS BEEN NECESSARILY AN INCREASE
--
THAT WOULD WARRANT THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CRIME
STATISTICS.
DIRECTLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WEBSITE YOU WILL SEE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF HOMICIDES
CENTER COMMITTEE GEORGE MAJORITY
OF GUN VIOLENCE HAS COMMITTED IS
WITH A HANDGUN.
NOT WITH THE RIFLE OR LONGER.
IN FACT IT'S ABOUT 85%.
THAT IS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WEBSITE SO IN MY VIEW
THIS BILL IS.
LOOKING FOR A PROBLEM THAT
DOESN'T EXIST AND THERE IS
ALREADY A PROHIBITION ON
PURCHASING MORE THAN ONE HANDGUN
IN THIRTY DAYS THAT HAS BEEN
LOST SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY WE DO NOT HAVE A
NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF BILL
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE
INCREASE THAT WOULD WARRANT THIS
TYPE OF LEGISLATION FOR FOR
THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK SOME OVER
SANTIAGO YOU MAY CLOSE.
I THINK AMEND SPEAKER AND I
APPRECIATE THE DEBATES UP BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE.
I BELIEVE ALONG WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT NO ONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE.
OUTSIDE OF THE EXEMPTIONS OF
MORE THAN ONE LONG GONE OUT PER
MONTH AND WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
NOW WHEN I DID THIS BILL SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND IT PASSED THIS
CHAMBER AYE HANDEDLY.
WE HAD UNCOVERED THAT THERE WAS
ONE INDIVIDUAL I AND TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN THAT HAD
BOUGHT MORE THAN I BELIEVE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR LONG
GUNS.
NO ONE NEEDS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FOUR NO ONE NEEDS TO HUNDRED OF
THESE THINGS TENDED THESE THINGS
OR THIRTY THE THINGS OUTSIDE OF
THE EXEMPTIONS THAT WE'VE JUST
STATED.
I TO ME IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE I
BELIEVE IT INCREASES THE ABILITY
THE GUN TRAFFIC AND THERE IS
SOME DATA THAT SHOWS THAT A LOT
OF THAT SOMEBODY MASS SHOOTINGS
HAVE NOW BEEN --
DONE BY LONG GUNS AND THE SOME
SOME OF THESE GUNS ON MAY HAVE
BEEN IN FACT --
PARTICIPATING.
I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY SIX THE MEASURE PASSES.
I AM SICK TO SIXTY NINE TO
SEVENTY AND TWO SEVENTY TO PASS
AND RETAIN ITEM.
TO SEVENTY THREE PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM TWO
SEVENTY FOUR S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
THREE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR GALGIANI AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR GALGIANI WILL REQUIRE
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TO DEVELOP
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
PREVENTION POLICIES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THE HIGHLY
SKILLED WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY ARE A
VITAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY DESPITE EFFORTS TO
RECRUIT WOMEN INTO THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
WOMEN MAKE UP JUST 3%.
CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL CONSTRUCTION
WORK FORCE IN ONLY TWO POINT 4%
OF THOSE ENROLLED IN THE
APPROACHES SHIP OF SYSTEM.
SP TWELVE TWENTY THREE ADDRESSES
THIS PROBLEM BY ESTABLISHING AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP AN
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC ANTI
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
POLICY AND STATE AND TRAINING
STANDARD FOR THE USE. FOR
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
BEST FAR IN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FREE AYE VOTE ON SENATE BILL
TWELVE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULE AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TO THE SEVENTY FIVE PASS
AND RETAIN.
ITEM TWO SEVENTY SIX PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
THREE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SEVERAL TWELVE SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
POLLUTION THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM HERE TO PRESENT SP
TWELVE SIXTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO.
IT REQUIRES THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL TO ADOPT AND IMPLEMENT A
STATEWIDE MICHAEL PLASTIC
STRATEGY ON OR BEFORE DECEMBER.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE OPC
TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
STATE WATER BOARD A WE HIGH AND
OTHER INTERESTED ENTITIES IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE STRATEGY.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL ALL OUR
ALLOWS THE OPC TO ENTER INTO ONE
OR MORE CONTRACTS WITH THE
MARINE REESE WITH MARINE
RESEARCH INSTITUTES.
THAT HAVE.
EXPERTISE RELATING TO THE
EFFECTS OF MICRO PROSPECTS ON
OCEAN HEALTH.
MICHAEL PLASTICS ARE UBIQUITOUS
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT YET THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT DATA TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A BROAD SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEM.
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY AS
CONTEMPLATED BY THIS BILL WILL
HELP.
MAKE YOU ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER. TO ITEM TWO THIRTY
THREE SB ELEVEN FIFTY TWO MATTER
PARK PLEASE PLEASE READ SET UP
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERNANDEZ AND ACT [inaudible]
LOOK HEALTH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
TWO IS ONE SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
PIECE OF ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
RESPONSE TO RECENT CASES OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS BEING
DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITALS LEFT
AT BUS STOPS OR SHELTERS.
THAT ARE UNABLE TO SERVE THEM.
SOMETIMES WEARING ONLY A
HOSPITAL GREAT DOWN WITH NO
WHERE TO GO.
THIS BILL REFLECTS THE NEEDS FOR
POSSIBLE TO BE PARTNERS IN
COMPASSIONATE TREATMENT OF
HOMELESS PATIENTS.
WE FACE TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS AND
HAVING ADEQUATE HOUSING AND
SOCIAL SERVICES RESOURCES.
THE BILL PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY
FOR HOSPITALS AND THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND MEET THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS.
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS HAVE
TAKEN MANY MANY AMENDMENTS OVER
TWENTY FIVE IN FACT TO INSURE
THAT THIS BILL CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED BY BOTH HOSPITALS
AND COMMUNITIES.
THE BILL NOW ALLOWS NONCLINICAL
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS OFFERING
CLOSER A MEAL TO BE DONE IN A
NON CLINICAL AREA THE HOSPITAL
SUCH AS A WAITING ROOM OR
CAFETERIA.
IN ADDITION THE BILL WAS AMENDED
TO PERU TO REMOVE PROVISIONS
THAT MAY HAVE RESULTED IN LONGER
HOSPITAL STAYS.
INCLUDING THE REQUIREMENT THAT
PATIENTS BE ALLOWED TO REMAIN IN
THE HOSPITAL UNTIL DAYLIGHT
HOURS.
IT ONLY REQUIRES HOSPITALS
IDENTIFIES SHELTER PLACEMENT
WERE AVAILABLE INTO OTHERWISE
HELP THE PATIENT TO RETURN TO A
LOCATION THAT IS FAMILIAR TO
THEM.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE A
HIGH PRIORITY FOR THIS
POPULATION RESOURCES ARE NOT
AVAILABLE IN ALL CASES SO THIS
BILL NOW REQUIRES HOSPITALS. TO
MAKE A GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
COORDINATE WITH APPROPRIATE
PROVIDERS.
I BELIEVE THAT S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY TWO IS A REASONABLE
APPROACH TO IT DIFFICULT
PROBLEM.
WITH THIS MEASURE CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER IN
FINDING COMPASSIONATE SOLUTIONS
AND TREATING EVERY PERSON WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE I SEE
SOMEBODY WAVING IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL.
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AS A POSITION
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT I'VE
EXPERIENCED THE DILEMMAS AND
CHALLENGES THAT COME WITH.
TREATING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AS DOCTORS WE PROVIDE ALL THE
MEDICAL CARE THAT WE CAN TO SAID
A PERSON ON THE ROAD TO HEALTH
AND RECOVERY.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT WHAT
HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF THE HOSPITAL
OFTEN BECOMES.
A THE BIGGER TO DETERMINES TO
WHETHER A PERSON RECOVERS WELL.
WHETHER THE PERSON HAS A PLACE
TO LIVE OR FOOD TO EAT IS
INSTRUMENTAL.
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS CANNOT
SOLVE ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS BUT
WE ARE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY TWO
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR BASIC
STEPS THAT CAN BE TAKEN WHEN THE
PERSON WHO IS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS PASSES THROUGH OUR
CARE.
IT ALSO PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY
SPUR HOSPITALS PHYSICIANS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS. TO PROVIDE THOSE
ESSENTIAL BUT NON CLINICAL
SERVICES IN A MANNER THAT DOES
NOT IMPEDE PATIENT FLOW OR CROWD
OUR FACILITIES.
FURTHERMORE WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE KERN WHO ARE CONNECTED
TO PRIMARY CARE TO MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND SHELTER ARE FAR LESS
LIKELY TO FREQUENT AND TO RETURN
TO OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
I BELIEVE THAT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO IS A REASONABLE
MEASURE WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
DIGNITY AND HUMANITY OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTES TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER WOULD YOU
WANT HOPE I NOW SEE ANOTHER MIKE
UP MEMBERS PLEASE PUT YOUR
MYSELF HE WAS.
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
ORECK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT AND CONCUR WITH
THAT.
COMMENTS FROM OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO WHO WITNESSED THIS FIRST
HAND AS AN ER DOC.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS IN MY
LOCAL CITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
FOR WELL OVER A DECADE.
SON CITIES HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS THIS ON THEIR OWN WITH
ORDINANCE IS.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S TIME THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THEY A STATEWIDE
SOLUTION WE KNOW THE HOSPITALS
ARE NOT THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
NOT TRYING.
TO PICK ON HOSPITALS WE MUST
COUNT ON HOUSE WILL BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
AND REQUIRING THAT LET THE
HOSPITAL STEP BUT IS THAT
CERTAINLY WISE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE ONE POSSIBLE
ESSENTIAL MEDICAL CARE AND ARE
HOMELESS.
ANOTHER HAS A A TRIAGE CENTER
WITH RESPITE BEDS FUNDED IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT WE'VE SEEN TOO
MANY BREAKDOWNS AND
COMMUNICATIONS AND TWO EXAMPLES
ARE FRANKLY.
PATIENT DUMPING AND THIS WAS
ADDING SOME STATEWIDE STANDARDS
BUT ALSO ALLOW HOSPITALS TO HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY BUT BASICALLY
MAKE THEM HAVE PLANS THAT THEY
HAVE.
AT THEIR READY DISPOSABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS MATTER UP A
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES.
ASK YOUR I DON'T.
I SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD BE
LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU WITHOUT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD HAVE MOVED
THE CAR
.
OKAY TWO ITEMS TO SEVENTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN TO SEVENTY NINE
PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM TO EIGHTY
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
TWO EIGHTY ONE SP THIRTEEN OH
ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NO ONE BY
SENATOR BALLOT OTHERS IN ATLANTA
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COVER
YOUR OR YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN OH ONE BY SENATOR BILL
BELL.
THIS BILL WILL HELP EXPEDITE
FLOOD AND DAM SAFETY PROJECTS
PER PROP BY PROVIDING PERMIT
APPLICANTS WITH A MECHANISM FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL CONSULTATION WITH
STATE AGENCIES.
THE FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS AND
DAM SAFETY ENHANCEMENTS CAN
REDUCE THE RISK OF NATURAL
DISASTERS AND OBVIOUSLY SAVE
LIVES.
THROUGH SOME SUPPLEMENTAL
CONSULTATION AGENCIES CAN
IDENTIFY ACTIONS TO HELP
EXPEDITE THE REQUIRED PERMITS.
CLARIFY IN DISCUSS ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS IN MITIGATION PROVIDE
FEEDBACK ON ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS AND POTENTIALLY
RESOLVE ANY CONFLICTS A PROJECT
APPLICANT WOULD PAY A FEE TO
COVER THE COST TO THE AGENCIES.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT ANY
PROJECT.
WILL STILL BE SUBJECT TO ALL OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESSES INCLUDING SIKA.
THIS BILL ENJOYS NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ON AVERAGE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWO EIGHTY TO PASS
TEMPORARILY MOVING TO ITEM TWO
EIGHTY THREE SB THIRTEEN TWELVE
MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND OTHERS EXACTLY THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TO SEE A RISE A PRESENT
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE A
CLEAN UP MEASURE THAT MODIFIES
DISABLED VETERANS SICK LEAVE
BENEFITS FOR STATE EMPLOYEES. TO
MATCH THOSE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
TO PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WILL BRING PARITY AB
TO THE BENEFIT LEVEL WE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE OF FOR THESE
GROUP OF VETERANS WITH THIS BILL
ALL DISABLED VETERANS IN STATE
SERVICE WE COVERED EQUALLY.
AND FAIRLY TO THE SAME BENEFITS
STANDARD ALONG WITH THE SAME
ACCOUNTABILITY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR JACKSON ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL FAR
VETERANS.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS WROTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS WHO.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
MADAM CLERK.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM TWO EIGHTY FOUR
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY BY SENATOR STERN AND
ACTUALLY TO ALTER OR DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
STERN.
WHAT S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY DOES
IS IT ADDS VICTIMS OF ELDER OR?
DEPENDENT ABUSE TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S SAFE AT HOME PROGRAM
SPILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS LED OBJECTION WE ARE
GOING TO BE RETURNING. TO ITEM
ONE FORTY SIX FOR
RECONSIDERATION MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SEVERAL SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS
UNLIKELY TO ELECTIONS GOING
DIFFERENCE EITHER UPS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU
WITH A WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
META PARKWAYS READ THE ITEM.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS NOT
PLAYING TO LECTURES TO PAY THEIR
AS THEY ARE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
YOU HEARD THIS ITEM [inaudible]
LAST FRIDAY.
S. B. TO PERMIT SB SEVEN FIFTY
NINE CREATES A PROCESS FOR LOCAL
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. TO NOTIFY
VOTERS WHEN THEY'RE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS SIGNATURE MIS MATCHES
THE ONE ON FILE.
IT ALSO GUARANTEES THOSE VOTERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THE
MISMATCH SO THAT THEIR VOTES.
CAN BE COUNTED.
AS THE USE OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY AS THE VOTERS CHOICE
ACT IS IMPLEMENTED IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES WE CANNOT IGNORE THIS
ISSUE ANY LONGER TODAY OVER HALF
OF CALIFORNIANS VOTE BY MAIL.
AND SOME COUNTIES CONDUCTED
ALEXIAN HIS BY MAIL INCLUDING
MINE SAN MATEO MEMBERS IT IS UP
TO US TO KEEP DEMOCRACY STRONG
AND PASS SB SEVEN FIFTY NINE
*. FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NOTICE O. ITENS DOT O.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM OUR SPEAKER I
STAND IN OPPOSITION NOT TO WITH
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT.
IT IS SAW OUGHT TO CREATE THE ON
EDITION ARE MANDATE TO ON
ALREADY OVERBURDENED ELECTIONS.
OUR ELECTION OFFICIALS I GOT
WOULD RESULT THAT IN AN INCREASE
IN ARE OF VOTER.
FRAUD.
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS ARE LIKELY
TO ALLOW.
A QUESTIONABLE SIGNATURE ASSAULT
ON VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS.
IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE THE NEED TO
VERIFY ON THE BACK END OF THE
ELECTION [inaudible]
THIS.
ON THE MINUS SIDE THE INTEGRITY
OF THE PROCESS.
A AT THE TIME WHEN THE NATIONAL.
DISCUSSION AND SO CENTER DON'T
ONE BALLOT AND THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY.
I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE.
FIVE I AM INCREASING CALIFORNIA
SAW OUT.
NO VOTO PARTICIPATION BUT I'M
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OFF OF THE
INTEGRITY AND THE SECURITY OF
OUR SYSTEMS.
I STRONGLY URGE AND THE RESPECT
REALLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES SO TO
JOIN ME IN OPPOSING.
SP YA [inaudible]
SEVEN FIFTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I AM SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THEY CAN ASK PETER JUST BRIEFLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND BALLOTS
WERE TOSSED OUT.
AND THE TWENTY SIXTEEN CYCLE
MANY OF WHICH I BELIEVE ARE
LEGITIMATE BALLOTS WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH A SIGNATURE MISMATCH
ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA LET'S BE A
LEADER.
ON THIS ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON MEMBERS BOTH
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
CLOSE THE ROLLER TALLY THE
VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FOUR NO TWENTY THREE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ON THE URGENCY AND ON THE BILL.
MEMBERS OF THAT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM ONE FORTY
SEVEN FOR RECONSIDERATION MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HELEN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE HEALTH
WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
MADAM QUICKLY THROUGH THE ITEM
ABOUT SENATE BILL AND TWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR HELEN OTHERS
ACTUALLY PEOPLE HEALTH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
YOU'D TO MEMBERS HEARD THIS UP
LAST FRIDAY THIS IS S. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN ON MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
HELP STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
MEDICAL DISABILITIES ATTEND
SCHOOL.
THE ONLY MEDICATION THAT WORKS
FOR SOME OF THE STUDENTS AS
MEDICAL CANNABIS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW A PARENT OR GUARDIAN TO
COME ON CAMPUS TO ADMINISTER
MEDICAL CANNABIS TO THEIR CHILD.
AND NON SMOKING AND NON VAPING
FORMS ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WILL
ALLOW THE GOVERNING BOARD OF K.
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION OR CHARTER
SCHOOL. TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
ADOPT THIS POLICY IT IS NOT A
STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES THAT
OFTEN CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING A FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THIS
POLICY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BROUGH DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY TWO NO.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY NINE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
CYNICAL TWELVE THIRTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND ACTUALLY
TO THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
SPEAKER PRESENTING SP TWELVE
THIRTY NINE AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
THIS BODY PASSED S. B..
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WHICH CALLED
ON THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
MODERNIZE AND STREAMLINE THE CAL
ACCESS DATABASE BY CREATING A
NEW ONLINE.
BASED SYSTEM S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
INE PROVIDES A LEGISLATIVE
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
THE CAL ACCESS REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM REQUIRES.
IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE BRING
CALIFORNIA'S CAL ACCESS SYSTEM
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY FOR VOTERS
AND ENSURE THEY HAVE FACILITATED
ACCESS. TO CAMPAIGN AND LOBBYING
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NEVER QUESTION
SPEAK MADAM  I'M SORRY THERE
IS A REQUEST TO SPEAK I BEG YOUR
PARDON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AMOUNT SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IS
VICE CHAIR OF THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE ORIGINALLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL BUT AFTER SEEING THE
CHANGES AND CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION I RISE IN SUPPORT
US MEASURE.
IT WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES TO FILE
THEIR FINANCIAL REPORTS ONLINE
ADDITIONALLY ELIMINATES
DUPLICATE OF PAPER FILINGS FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE FILED ONLINE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT INCREASES
TRANSFER ARE TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM.
SYSTEMS AND I ARE VERY MUCH I
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
WILL YOU ACCEPT THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES.
YES THAT MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO ARE VOTING ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
THREE THIRTY ONE S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY MADAM COURT PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY PRESENTING S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY BY SENATOR DODD
PERTAINING TO MEDIA LITERACY
EDUCATION.
THE RISE OF FAKING MISLEADING
NEWS IS DEEPLY CONCERNING A
RECENT STANFORD STUDY FOUND THAT
82% OF MEDICALS MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS STRUGGLE TO DISTINGUISH
ADVERTISEMENTS FROM NEW STORIES.
WHAT WE HAVE CRITICAL THINKING
REQUIREMENTS IN OUR CURRICULUM
THEY HAVEN'T KEPT UP WITH THE
DIGITAL AGE S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
REQUIRES THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MAKE AVAILABLE TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS?
THROUGH ITS WEBSITE RESOURCES
AND INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS ON
MEDIA LITERACY INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TEACHERS BY GIVING STUDENTS THE
PROPER TOOLS TO ANALYZE THE
MEDIA THEY CONSUME WE CAN
EMPOWER THEM TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION IS
SUPPORTED BY A COALITION OF
EDUCATION AND CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY GROUPS HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
ASK FOR YOUR RIGHT.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
SECOND READING CONCURRENCE
ITEMS.
TWO THROUGH FOUR PASS AND RETAIN
ITEM FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM SIX AB.
TWENTY TO FORTY EIGHT MATTER
QUICKLY.
THREE S. ILLEGAL TWENTY FORTY
EIGHT PRICE ONLY MEMBER MCCARTY
AND OTHERS NOTHING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY YOUR
RECOMMENDED SPEAKER.
I CAN'T FIND THE PAPER HERE BUT
I THINK THIS IS A PRETTY SIMPLE
BILL BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
NOTES RELATED TO OUR EFFORTS TO
HAVE STUDENTS GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
PUSHING ARE STILL NEED
COMMISSION. TO TO INFORM
STUDENTS OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
TAKING MORE THAN FOUR YEARS AND
THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
I ASK FOR THE SUPPORT OF OF
SENATE [inaudible]
ENCOURAGED AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN A NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CARCASS OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE END TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVEN E. B. SIX
FIFTY THREE MADAM QUICKLY THREE
ASSEMBLY WILL SIX FIFTY THREE BY
SOME A MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
ACTUALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIX
FIFTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THAT WOULD HELP
ENABLE.
THE LOMPOC VALLEY HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT TO SET UP A JPA THAT
WOULD INCREASE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE SERVICES IN THE
REGION.
VERY UNDERSERVED REGION IT
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MEDI
PURPOSE OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTE
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE METAPHOR PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER
DALY ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT
GROUP LIFE INSURANCE POLICIES
MAY COVER FORMER EMPLOYEES AND
RETIREES.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN OF
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NINE PASS TEMPORARILY ITEM
TEN PASS AND RETAIN.
I AM ELEVEN PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM TWELVE A B. SIX
EIGHTY SIX MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAN SPEAKER
TODAY I STAND BEFORE --
THIS BODY PRESENTING AB SIX
EIGHT SIX WHICH HAVE BEEN TWO
YEARS IN THE MAKING.
WE WORK WITH THIS HOUSE AND THE
SENATE HOUSE.
AND THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT FAIR HOUSING STILL EXISTING
CALIFORNIA.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN THREATENED
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I IN CONGRESS.
I THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
A BILL IT'S ONE THING I TO
PREVENT DISCRIMINATION IT'S A
WHOLE NOTHER TO SEGREGATE AND WE
BELIEVE.
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIC A STAND AND
A AND A B. SIX EIGHT SIX I WOULD
PREVENT A SEGREGATION THANK YOU.
THINK YOU IS SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM
HARKLESS OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY TWO NO NINETEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
BE EIGHTEEN A FIVE MATTER PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER CALDERON AND
OTHERS LIKELY POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLOR
ON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILL REQUIRES PARTICIPATING
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES TO CREATE PROCEDURES
FOR INCOME BASED REPAYMENT PLANS
FOR DREAM LOANS.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE AT CO AUTHORS --
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM AND QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT NO ONE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT MATTER PARK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SOME THE MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
PROMOTE PROCEDURE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT WAS AMENDED
IN THE SENATE AT SENATOR STONE
AS A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL HAS
GONE TO BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCLUDED.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTEEN A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
ATLANTA PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
ARIZA PRESENT AB NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
COUNTIES TO USE TEXT MESSAGING
TO COMMUNICATE WITH CALIFORNIANS
WHO RELY ON SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CAL FRESH.
AND CAL WORKS WOULD ALSO ENSURE
THAT TEXT MESSAGING OCCURS UNDER
SEVEN IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS SENATE AMENDMENTS
NARROW THE FOCUS OF THE BILL. TO
TO SECURE DELIVERY OF TEXT
MESSAGES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SING A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MADAME FOR PLEASE OPEN.
A MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TIED THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM AT SIXTEEN A. B.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CAN'T CHIU AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE HEALTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM OF
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWENTY TWOS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THE AMENDMENT REQUIRES TO SCHOOL
NOTIFY STUDENTS AND PARENTS
TWICE A YEAR ABOUT HOW TO ACCESS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THIS BILL RECEIVED NO NO VOTE IN
THE SENATE AND IS SUPPORTED BY
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT.
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
WILL.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MEDICAL CAN MAKE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY THIRTY SIX MAC QUICKLY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY TO THE STATE
CAPITOL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED BETTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX WHICH IS BACK
ON CURRENTS ASSEMBLY THE
AMENDMENTS --
FROM THE SENATE OUR TECHNICAL IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BOTH.
DEBATE METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THROUGH DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR ABOUT A PARK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY FOUR
BY SOME THE MEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS BILLS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS IS THE BILL THAT PROTECTS
CHILDREN IN CUSTODY BATTLES FROM
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS NARROW THE
BILL SLIGHTLY AND ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS FROM JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AS WELL AS THE FAMILY LAW BAR I
ASK FOR AND I VOTING
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF OUR AB TWENTY
FORTY FOUR YOU HEARD LAST WEEK
--
AND YOU VOTED ON UP BECAUSE
RESOLUTION IF THIS LAW WAS IN
PLACE THEN THAT MIGHT HAVE
HELPED PEAKY BE ALIVE TODAY SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A STRONG
AYE VOTE FOR AB.
TWENTY FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
SEEING NO FURTHER REQUEST TO
SPEAK MEDICAL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM* YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
ACTUALLY THE MEDI CAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SIMPLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
ONE UTILIZES TELEHEALTH SERVICES
TO HELP WITH.
A SUBSTANCE ABUSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSABLE
IMITATION.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION MADAM COURT
PLEASE OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY EIGHT B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY FIVE AS A MEDIC
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
FORTY FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
SALAS ACT LINDA STEVE PLAYS
MAKING PREPARATION THEREFORE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
FIVE IS BACK ON CONCURRENT SO
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE MINOR
TECHNICAL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I THINK YOU'VE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MATTER
PURPOSE OPEN.
NO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
PROVE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
FOUR NEW ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B.
THREE SEVENTY TWO MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IF YOU
MEADOW SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB THREE SEVENTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE BECAUSE OF SOME
CHALLENGES FORM CERTAIN
COUNTIES.
AND THERE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THEIR BATTER.
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS WE'VE NOW
LIMIT THIS TO SIX COUNTIES WHO
WANT TO TAKE PART IN THIS PILOT
PROGRAM AND SO WHAT THE PILOT
PROGRAM WILL DO WILL
DEMONSTRATE.
THE ABILITY FOR COUNTIES TO USE
A BEST PRACTICES AND DATE
INFORMED PROCESSES TO ENSURE
THAT THE BATTER INVENT A
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS ARE IN
FACT WORKING AND WE CAN REDUCE
THE 80%.
RECIDIVISM RATE THAT WE SEE IN
BATTERERS THIS IS TO MOVE THE
PROGRAM'S FORWARD ENSURE THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN OUR COUNTIES AT
LEAST IN THE SIX PILOT.
COUNTIES I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
IN CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULE TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW IN ITEM TWENTY TWO A.
B. EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
BY SOME THE NUMBER THE VIENEN
ACTUALLY TO SENTENCING THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE MEMBERS YOU MAY
REMEMBER IN MY FIRST TERM I
AUTHORED ALIVE THAT.
ALLOWED FOR SERVICE MEMBERS WHO
HAD --
SERVICE INDUCEMENT TO HEALTH
PROBLEMS THEIR SENTENCE FOR A
CRIME THEY WOULD HAVE THAT BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
THAT WAS PROSPECT OF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT SINCE
THEN I'VE WORKED HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO VETERAN WOULD BE
LEFT BEHIND ON THIS ISSUE AND
THIS BILL ALLOWS TO GO BACK IN
TIME PRIOR TO TWENTY FIFTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARKING HEARD IN.
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND ACTUALLY TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE EXPANDS A LIST OF
MANDATORY ELEMENTS.
OF THE STATE'S INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AND INVESTMENT STRATEGY TO
INCLUDE THE ROLE OF LOGISTICAL
HUB THAN INLAND PORT.
THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF PORT FACILITIES
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCING THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
BANK THE EYE BANG. TO INCLUDE
INLAND PORTS.
DATE TO THE STATE TRADE TRADE
STRATEGY FOR FIVE MONTHS TO
ALLOW TIME FOR THE NEXT GOVERNOR
TO DEVELOP THE STRATEGY I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE RUN ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEDICARE PLEASE CLOSER ON TELLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
I'M SORRY MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
S. LABEL SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN BY
SOME A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS ACT WHEN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MAKING PREPARATION
THERE.
FOR NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS AND
TIMELINES FOR SUBMITTING
PROPOSALS TO GO BIDS ON
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT. TO OPERATE IN
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AND FOREIGN
INVESTMENT OFFICE THE SENTIMENT
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE
TECHNICAL AND NON STE OUGHT NOT
SUBSTANTIATED STRANGE'S AND WE
WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY FIVE A. B.
EIGHTEEN NO ONE MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN NO ONE BY
SOME THE MEMBER DOES AREA AND
ACTUALLY TO NEWBORNS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN ASSYRIAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN OH ONE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION TO REVIEW ISSUE
SURROUNDING CYTOMEGALOVIRUS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CMB.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE REVISED
THE COMMISSION'S MEMBERSHIP AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AB TWO NO
ONE HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN IT NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MADAME PARK PLEASE
OPEN THE RIDE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARKING CURTIN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ITEM FOR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER DOES
AREA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
BUILDING STANDARDS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE
A WORKING GROUP TO INVESTIGATE
NEW.
POST EARTHQUAKE BUILDING
STANDARDS OUR CURRENT CODE IS
ONLY DESIGNED TO PROTECT AGAINST
LOSS OF LIFE IN A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE.
BUT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT WHETHER
OR A A BUILDING WHETHER OR WHEN
A BUILDING WILL BE USABLE AFTER
A LARGE SEISMIC EVENT THIS BILL
IS THE FIRST STEP TO GETTING
CALIFORNIANS.
BACK INTO BUILDINGS AFTER A
LARGE EARTHQUAKE INSTEAD OF
HAVING BUILDINGS CLOSED FOR
MONTHS OR YEARS AT A TIME SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION THE BILL AND I
RESPECT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING I REQUEST TO
SPEAK MADAM PARK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
NOT A QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINETEEN NINETY TWO
MADAME CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
TWO BY SOME A MEMBER KANSEN CHU
ATLANTA CHO WORKS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SENATE
MAMMON REMOVED FINANCIAL
BURDENS.
PENALTIES ON POOR FAMILIES WHILE
RETAINING LANGUAGES TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR PARENTS TO OBTAIN
NECESSARY NEWMAN IDEATION AND
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
A LESS HELP THOSE STRUGGLING
FAMILY INSTEAD OF POLLUTION DOWN
VERDE INTO PROPERTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAME PART PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON [inaudible]
MEMBERS BOTH AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY SIX NO FIFTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY EIGHT E.
B. TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT BASED ON THE NUMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACT ON THE
PRESIDENT'S THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MOUNT SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE THE BILL ENSURES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS ARE.
SECURE SITES FOR INMATE STAFF IN
THE PUBLIC.
AB TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
REQUIRE CDC ARE TO CONDUCT
PHYSICAL SECURITY APPROACH.
INSPECTIONS AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REPAIRS
BASED ON REST AND TO MAKE TIMELY
REPAIR SHOULD.
RESOURCE WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
A RESTORED GAS FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE METAPHOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
BENEFIT YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCORD IN.
ITEM TWENTY NINE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY AB TWENTY
FORTY SIX MADAM COURT PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DALY YOU RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS A MEASURE TO COMBAT
WORKERS' COMPENSATION FRAUD.
THE BILL ADDRESSES DATA SHARING
AMONG THE VARIOUS GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES INVOLVED IN THIS
EFFORT.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
PROCEDURES IN THE EVENT THERE IS
A CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW.
OR IF A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IS NOT ALREADY AUTHORIZED BY LAW
TO RECEIVE CERTAIN CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NEVER CROSSED
TO SPEAK MEADOW PARKING UP IN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARK PREFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY ONE AB
TWENTY ONE OH THREE MADAM
QUICKLY STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER GLORIA
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY FIREARMS
THINK HE WAS A MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE OH
THREE WHICH IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE.
I WITH A FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
SOME AMENDMENTS.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL AND AT CO AUTHORS THIS
BILL MEMBERS OUR MIND YOU OF
ACQUIRES ALL TRAINING COURSES.
CURRENTLY REQUIRED FOR CONCEALED
CARRY WEAPON LICENSES TO BE AT
LEAST EIGHT HOURS IN LENGTH.
AB TWENTY ONE OH THREE ALSO
REQUIRES CONCERT LOOK AT ITS TO
DEMONSTRATE SAFE HANDLING AND
PROFICIENCY OF A FIREARM ON THE
FIRING RANGE.
I'M PROUD REPORT THAT SINCE THIS
BILL WAS BEFORE THIS BODY.
AS IT'S AFTER THIS BILL WAS
BEFORE THIS BODY --
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION JOIN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORTING AB.
TWENTY ONE OH THREE I THINK ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
SUPPORT TODAY INCLUDING MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN BOTH
THIS FLOOR AND IN THE SENATE
FIRST THEIR AYE VOTES ON THIS
MATTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
HIVE OF THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS BACK.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CHANGE THAT
NEEDED TO BE MADE WASN'T MADE
WHICH IS.
IT SET THE BILL SAYS IT IT WILL
NOT REQUIRE THAT MORE THAN
SIXTEEN HOURS OF TRAINING --
BE IMPOSED ON CCW HOLDERS IT
DOESN'T TAKE CAN'T BE MORE THAN
THAT IT JUST SAYS YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED. TO MAKE IT SIXTEEN
HOURS MEANING.
YOU COULD HAVE A COUNTY THAT
MAKES IT. TWENTY HOURS OR FORTY
HOURS ARE HUNDRED EIGHTY HOURS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH
THIS BILL IS THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE A CAP --
SO FOR THAT REASON I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FOR THE
REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
I AM SORRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MENACE
SUGAR QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
HAVE YOU EVER A TRAINED ON ANY
FIREARMS.
YOU CAN ANSWER NOW OR IN YOUR
CLOTHES. TO SIMPLY ANSWER YES.
ABOUT NO DEBATE YOU CAN ANSWER
IT NOW OR YOU CAN ANSWER THIS
CLOSE.
MR MATHIS YOU CAN CONTINUE.
IT IS MORE LIKE ON THANK YOU ON
ON MY OWN TIME I JUST YOU KNOW
BEING A SOME OF THOSE IN THE
MILITARY THAT WAS ON IN A
TRAINED FOR TEN YEARS PEOPLE ON
FIREARMS.
A F. FIND IT REALLY INTERESTING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO GO AFTER
ALL.
CCW IS EXPRESSLY BECAUSE THERE'S
ALREADY TRAINING MECHANISM IN
PLACE.
AND YOU KNOW THESE BILLS IT IS
WE'RE GONNA SECOND OR AS WE GET
INTO THESE THINGS.
THE USER THE LEAST AMOUNT.
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
PROBLEMS THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE OUT ON THE STREETS
THEY'RE DOING THINGS ILLEGALLY.
THESE ARE THE ONES THAT GO
THROUGH THE HIDEOUS PRACTICES TO
GO THROUGH EVERY SINGLE.
THING THAT THEY'RE ASKED TO JUMP
THROUGH.
SO THEY CAN PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILY BUT YEAH AS A
BODY.
WE SEEM TO CONTINUE TO GO AFTER
THEM ON LET'S JUST ADD ONE MORE
THING ONE MORE THING ONE MORE
THING.
SO THE AGAIN MY QUESTION GOES TO
I'M I'M INTERESTED IN THE
AUTHORS --
TRAINING IN HIS BACKGROUND ON ON
ACTUALLY KNOWING ABOUT WEAPONS
IN THE TRAINING --
WHILE HE'S RUNNING THIS
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC.
TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T NEED TO KEEP ADDING
BURDENS TO IT.
AND OF COURSE MY COLLEAGUES
RAISE THEIR MICROPHONES YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WANT TO DEBATE THESE
THINGS THAT'S WHAT THE FLOOR.
FOR SO ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
THINK ABOUT LEE LET'S LOOK AT
THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY GOING
[inaudible]
TO STOP [inaudible]
CRIMINAL ELEMENTS.
VERSUS TAKING AWAY PROTECTIONS
FROM RIGHTEOUS CITIZENS AS FOR
NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE OH THREE I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
THIS EXCELLENT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
I JUST RISE WITH THE PERSPECTIVE
OF A PARENT AND SOMEBODY WHO'S
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RISE AN
INCREASE IN VIOLENCE IN OUR
SOCIETY I THINK THAT.
A LOT OF US THINK AND FEEL THAT
WE NEED TO DO MORE TO A
CRACKDOWN ON GUN VIOLENCE AND I
THINK THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE KEEP IN MIND
THAT THESE ARE COMMON SENSE
MEASURES THAT FOLKS ARE TAKING
AND I THINK THAT WHEN THERE'S
RESISTANCE TO COMMONSENSE
MEASURES IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING.
THAT'S TRYING TO TAKE AWAY
PEOPLE'S FIREARMS THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S TRYING TO
IMPOSE ON REASONABLE STANDARDS
ON FOLKS THIS IS A COMMONSENSE
PROCEDURE THAT'S GONNA PUT
CALIFORNIA LINE WITH TWENTY FIVE
OTHER STATES.
THAT ALREADY REQUIRE INDIVIDUALS
TO RECEIVE LIVE FIRE TRAINING
AND SO IN THE SPIRIT OF
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTING OUR CITIZENS I
RESPECTFULLY OCCUR CHEN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER OUT YOU
KNOW THIS MEASURE IS NOT --
PUT FORWARD AS WAS NOTED AS A
FEEL GOOD MEASURE THIS WAS BORN
OUT OF RESEARCH FROM OUR STATE
AUDITOR. TWO YEARS AGO I ASKED
STATE AUDITOR TO LOOK INTO THREE
COUNTIES AT THE CCW PRACTICES
RELATED.
TO TRAINING --
FEES WHETHER NOT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE SUBSIDIZING
THESE PROGRAMS.
AND THE STATE ARE CAME OUT WITH
A REPORT ABOUT A YEAR AGO
LOOKING AT THREE COUNTIES
SHOWING THAT IN MANY INSTANCES
INCLUDING RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
LA AND SAN DIEGO POLICIES THAT'S
WEREN'T CONSISTENT WITH STATE
LAW AND THE BACKGROUND AND
TRAINING ELEMENTS TO THESE --
WERE BASICALLY AT NOT UP TO PAR
AND SO THIS MEASURE IT TAKES
INTO THESE BEST PRACTICES AND
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A STATEWIDE
UNIFORM PROCESS RELATED.
TO SEE CW'S ARE THE LAW OF THE
LAND WE HAVE ANOTHER DEBATE IN
THEIR DAY ABOUT THAT BUT THE
MINUTE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A MINIMUM --
TRAINING A THRESHOLD FOR PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WHO GET THESE
LICENSES MAKE YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN
YOU'RE RIGHT [inaudible]
THE OTHER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'LL LEAVE IT
UP TO HIM AS TO WHAT THEIR
ANSWERS NOW OUR DISCLOSE DOES
YOUR MOTHER KNOW HOW MANY
VIOLENT CRIMES WERE COMMITTED BY
CCW HOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA LAST
YEAR.
I THOUGHT MY HEAD SIR BUT THERE
ARE THOUSANDS I'LL TELL YOU THE
ANSWER THE ANSWER IS ACTUALLY.
ZERO ZERO CRIMES ARE COMMITTED
LAST YEAR BY HOLDERS OF C. CW'S
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ASK SECOND QUESTION THE
AUTHOR HEY THIS IS NOT A DEBATE
YOU CAN ASK HIM HE CAN REPLY AND
HIS CLOTHES MADAM CHAIR I'M NOT
DEBATING I'M SIMPLY ASKING A
QUESTION AND ACTUALLY.
I WOULD I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT YOU SPOKE FROM TULARE THAT
THAT FLOOR IS ACTUALLY WHERE
DEBATE.
IS SUPPOSED TO BE HELD FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WE LIVE IN
A REPRESENTATIVE CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC WHERE THIS IS THE FLOOR
THE PEOPLE SPEAK AND THIS IS THE
FORWARD DEBATE IN THIS ALLEN YOU
CAN ABSOLUTELY DEBATE WITHIN
YOUR FIVE MINUTES.
BUT YOU WITH THIS IS NOT A PLACE
FOR CROSS EXAMINATION OR HUMAN A
YOU CAN ASK ME YEAH THEY ARE NOT
ACQUIRE ITEMS I DO APPRECIATE
THAT BUT I CHOOSE NOT TO DEBATE
WITH MYSELF.
I THIS IS ACTUALLY THE FLOOR
DEBATE IS HELD BETWEEN MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY SO WITH WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE.
OUR QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS HAVE AN INVIOLABLE
RIGHT. TO BEAR ARMS AS GIVEN
THEM BY THE U. S. CONSTITUTION
THAT SHALL NOT BE INFRINGED.
ADDRESS IN MY CLOTHES MISS.
WE CAN RESPOND AND IN HIS DEBATE
IN HIS CLOSING.
WELL YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'LL BE
PLEASED TO BE DEBATING WITH
YOURSELF BUT WE'LL BE WATCHING
ON YOUTUBE AS YOU MISS
MISTAKENLY SPOKE.
AND SAID YOU THOUGHT THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF CRIME THE CRIMES
COMMITTED BY CCW HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR.
YOUR ACTUALLY CORRECT MY FRIEND
THERE BEEN ZERO NOW I WILL TELL
YOU FOR ONE THAT I DO BELIEVE
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WALLS
ALL U. S. CITIZENS.
HAVE AN INVIOLABLE RIGHT
GUARANTEED BY THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS WHICH SHALL NOT BE
INFRINGED.
I IN THE CZW OLDER MYSELF AND I
CHOOSE NOT TO HAVE MY OWN RIGHTS
INFRINGED YES I DID GO THROUGH
TRAINING CLASS YES I AM LICENSE
AND YES I AM REGISTERED.
I THINK THAT IN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AS THIS BODY WOULD
TRY TO PUT ON LAW ABIDING
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND BY THE
WAY.
LET ME ALSO REFLECT THE CCW
CALIFORNIA IS PROBABLY THE
SAFEST PERSON YOU WERE EVER
GOING TO FIND OUTSIDE OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
I PRAY TO GOD THAT THERE'S A CCW
HOLDER WALKING ON EVERY SINGLE
STREET EVERY SINGLE CD EVERY
SINGLE TOWN EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
NIGHT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
MAKE US SAFER WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS MINUTES AWAY.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD SAY THE
LAWS ON THE BOOKS WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW ARE KEEPING US SAFE.
AS BORNE OUT BY THE EVIDENCE
ZERO VIOLENT CRIMES AND MANY
CRIMES HAVE BEEN PREVENTED BY
VALID HOLDERS OF CZW IS DOING
THERE EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
AND PEOPLE AROUND THEM FROM
VIOLET INJURY AND VIOLENT THREAT
I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS AND I
WOULD REINFORCE THE COMMENTS OF
THE MEMBER FROM TULARE I THINK
USE EXACTLY SPOT ON AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EVERY SINGLE MEMBER.
IN THIS BODY TO REMEMBER WHAT
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION ACTUALLY
STANDS FOR AND THAT'S THE RULE
OF LAW ARJUNA VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER
SAYA.
FIRST I I ACTUALLY HAVE A CCW.
I SUPPORTED THIS BILL.
AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL
AGAIN.
MOST OF US TO CARRY THOSE ARE
ALREADY DOING EIGHT HOUR COURSE
I THINK THAT THERE IS THAT
WHAT'S BEING MISSED HERE.
IS THAT WE HAVE.
LILY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CRIMINALS THAT ARE FELONS OUT
THERE.
THAT HAVE GUNS THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING AFTER WE'RE MAKING IT
HARDER FOR PEOPLE WHO.
OUR CHINA BY THE LAW MAKE IT
HARDER TO ACTUALLY.
YOU KNOW WE'RE PUTTING MORE
BURDEN ON THEM WHO ARE LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS YOU CANNOT GET
A CCW WITHOUT YOUR SHARE OF
SIGNING OFF OF IT IN YOUR
COUNTY.
AFTER YOU WENT TO ALL THAT THE
COURSES SO FOR ME THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER LAYER OF ADDING MORE.
BUREAUCRACY WHICH HAS ALREADY
BEEN DONE BUT I THINK WHAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON IS THAT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CRIMINALS THAT
ARE OUT THERE WITH GUNS THAT WE
SHOULD GO AFTER SAID A PASSING
LAWS THAT MOST SHERIFFS ALREADY
DO.
ARGENEAU AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU I'M NOT SAYING ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN A MY COLLEAGUES FOR
RAISING VOICES BOTH IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NO NATURALLY. TO TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF WHAT WAS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WHAT I FEEL
ABOUT INDIVIDUALS RIGHT TO CARRY
A GUN -- IS
NOT MY BUSINESS IT'S THAT IT
THAT IT IS A RIGHT IN WITHIN THE
U. S. CONSTITUTION SO QUESTION A
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
RELEVANT TO THIS DEBATE.
I THINK I WANT ALSO POINT OUT OF
FOR THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM BY
CELIA QUESTIONS ASKED ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCES OF WITH GUNS I WILL
TELL YOU --
MY COLLEAGUE I WAS ON THE
VARSITY RIFLE TEAM FRESHMAN YEAR
HIGH SCHOOL SPENT FOUR YEARS --
US PRETTY DARN GOOD AT DOING
THAT.
AND I DID IT BECAUSE I WAS
TRAINED BY SOMEONE WHO KNEW WHAT
THEY WERE DOING I WAS NOT GIVEN
A FIREARM AND SENT FORTH OUT
INTO THE WORLD.
I WAS GIVEN PROPER TRAINING
FRESHMAN YEAR VARSITY THAT WAS
ME THAT WAS THE ONLY SPORT I
COULD EVER POSSIBLY LETTER AND I
ONE OF MY MY COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
NO THAT.
SO PLEASE DO NOT ASSUME THAT I
DON'T UNDERSTANDING ABOUT FIRE
ARMS BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE WRONG
IN THE SAME WAY THAT I'M NOT
GONNA JUDGE YOU FOR HAVING A CCW
PERMIT.
BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT IF
YOU WANT TO HAVE A LOADED GUN IN
PUBLIC.
YOU NEED TO SHOW THAT YOU'VE
KNOWN WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NOT
UNIFORM RULES AROUND THIS THERE
ARE COUNTIES THAT ARE LACKS.
IN THEIR DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
PERMITS NOW I WOULD SAY MORE
POORLY THE WEATHER NOT TODD
GLORIA KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT
FIREARMS YOU KNOW DOES LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES THEY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THE POLICE CHIEF AND
THE SHERIFFS HAVE ENDORSED A YES
POSITION ON THIS.
BILL SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION IS PRETTY CLEAR ON
PRETTY CLEAR BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
CLEAR AND WHAT'S CLEAR IS YOU
NEED TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL
THAT'S BILLS FIVE EXPECT WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO APPLAUSE PLEASE MADAM CLERK
YOU MAY OPEN.
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS TWELVE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY TO E..
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE MR CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER OF A
CABALLERO AND I BELIEVE THE
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRIER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
IN SENATE AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE ADDED
STUDENTS WHO ARE RECENT
IMMIGRANTS PARTICIPATING IN A
NEWCOMER PROGRAM.
THAT THAT HOUSES THERE OBJECTIVE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ENGLISH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CLARK WAS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE A
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE
KNOWS ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENT
CERTAIN HEARD IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO MISTER
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW ONE ACT
PLAY INTO INSURANCE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
THANK YOU MINUTE SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE APPRECIATED AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MADAM CLERK
I. SORRY.
ROOM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK MAY CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER GREAT
OTHERS AND I PLAYED A HONEY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THEY MANISTIQUE
REMEMBERS THIS IS A MODEST BILL
TO ADDRESS THE DECLINE IN.
OUTDOOR SPORTING ACTIVITIES AND
PROMOTE CONSERVATION IT IS --
SUPPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
HUNTING AND CONSERVATION
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS AMONGST OTHERS THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION BACK OUR
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS DRIVE VOTE.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN ABOVE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRING TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY THREE
KNOWS TOO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSUME IT'LL
TWENTY ONE FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER ACCOLADE TO
CAL FRESH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER YES MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THE AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY TWO IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS NEARLY
NARAL THE BIZ BILL'S PROVISIONS
OF AT REQUIREMENTS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
DEVELOP A TOOL FOR FOOD
INSECURITY AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS
DEPRAVATION.
AND TO DISTRIBUTE THAT TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
WITH GUIDANCE ON HOW TO USE IT
THIS BILL HAVE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
RAW.
NUMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
THREE KNOWS NINE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO MISTER
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS AND ACT LIKE A STATE
FUNDED RESEARCH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
GIVE MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ADD
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
FROM THE UC AND CSU I ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS WILL
[inaudible]
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY.
LOS THE RULING TALLY THE VOTES
AYE SIXTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
EIGHT BE TWENTY TWO OH TO MR
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AN ACT
RELATING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU IT'S A
MEMBER GRAY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TO GO TO IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL CREATES A FUNDING IN
THE STATE TREASURY FOR THE
POSITIVE BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
FUNDING FOR THE CREATION OF AN
ENDOWMENT TO SUPPORT THE
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION.
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
INADEQUACIES OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HEALTHCARE INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE WELL DOCUMENTED WE DISCUSS
THEM AT LENGTH ON THIS FLOOR AND
IN OUR COMMITTEES.
THE DOW IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING POOREST AND LEAST
HEALTHY REGIONS OF THE STATE HAS
A LONGSTANDING SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS.
ESTABLISHMENT OF A MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
WILL ALLOW THE TRAINING OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS WHO WERE BORN
AND RAISED IN THE REGION AND WHO
HAVE ROOTS IN THE REGION TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE.
CLOSE TO HOME THIS IS SUPPORTED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN IN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER COURT PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES HIGH SIXTEEN NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX MISTER COR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX BY SOME MEMORABLE WALDRON
ACRYLATE HEALING ARTS LICENSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
BILLS A CLEAN UP MEASURE THAT
MAKES TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES TO THE LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELOR
ACT.
AND ADDRESSES TRAP DURING OUT
ISSUES AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE MEMBERS FOOD DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOW ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY NINE E. B.
THIRTY TWO OWE TO MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY TWO WILL TO
BUY FROM THE BERMAN BAKER AND
OTHERS ARE NOT WILLING TO
MANDATE REPORTERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
MEASURES BACK ON CONCURRENCE
FROM THE SENATE AND WHERE WAS
CHANGED TO HAVE A FIVE YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS BY WHICH
A MANDATED REPORTER WHO FAILS TO
REPORT SUSPECTED CHILD SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
CAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE THAT IS
CHANGING THE STATUE IMITATIONS
FROM ONE YEAR BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE IS TOO LITTLE AMOUNT OF
TIME.
WE HAVE A ONE YEAR STATUTE
LIMITATIONS FOR PICKING A
HUCKLEBERRY OFF OF PUBLIC LAND.
AND FOR CARING ACT AEROSOL PAINT
CAN.
SHOULD HAVE A STRONGER STATURE
LIMITATIONS FOR FAILURE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN FROM SEXUAL
ASSAULT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE TYPICAL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY EIGHT BE
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SEVEN MISTER
QUICKLY THREE SO MIDDLE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SEVEN VICE IN THE
RIVER GIPSON ANOTHER PERSON
ACTUALLY TO NON MINOR TO PAY
[inaudible]
MISTER GIBSON.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS OUT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN IS BACK ON THE
FLOOR FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED --
NO OPPOSITION RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT I VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES EYES SIXTY TWO
NO.
ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY ONE TWENTY
THREE SIXTEEN MISTER CLARK
FLINTRIDGE SUMMER BILL TWENTY
THREE SIXTY BY SOME MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACCOLADES
[inaudible]
NUTRITION THANK YOU SOME MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOUR RECOGNIZE.
BUT I'M SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
WHICH IS BACK A CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL WILL FACILITATE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL FOOD BANKS
TO INCREASE STUDENT ACCESS TO
FRESH PRODUCE FOOD ITEMS.
SOME AMENDMENTS MOVE THE BILL
FROM THE AGRICULTURE CODE TO THE
EDUCATION CODE ALONG WITH OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I WROTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK.
THE COURT PLEASE OPEN THE RUN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY TWO AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX MR
COURT PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY THREE SEVEN
SIX BLOCKS WE WERE MARK STONE
AND ACCOLADES CIVIL ACTIONS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CLARIFYING I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY THREE AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER ARAMBULA
AN ACCOLADE TO APPEASE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
OR A COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER TO IMPOSE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL PENALTY FOR
A VIOLATION OF CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS REGULATING THE
REGISTRATION AND IDENTIFICATION.
OF AB AREAS AND THE RELOCATION
OF BEE COLONIES BEGINNING ON
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY A
BEAD TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BEEKEEPERS ASSOCIATION.
MEMBERS THIS BILL HAS IS ALL THE
BUGS AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT SEEING
NO REQUEST TO SPEAK A QUICK QUIZ
OPEN THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES I SIXTY TO NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COULD HURT IN.
ITEM FORTY FOUR PASS AND RETAIN
A MOVING TO ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX WHO WON MISTER QUIRK
PLEASE READ.
ASSUMING BILL TWENTY SIX A ONE
BY SO MEMORABLE WEBER AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SIX OH ONE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENT SIMPLY
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION TO THE
ACADEMIC YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE THANK YOU SING I
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER CORPUS
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOWED.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THE BIG ITEM FORTY SIX AB TWENTY
SIX OH WAIT MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX A WEEK
BY SIMPLY RIVER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS AND I PLAYED THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS THE BILL THAT PROVIDES
ACCESS TO FORMER FOSTER YOUTH TO
GRADUATE DEGREES IN SOCIAL WORK.
SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE FEE
AND THEREFORE REMOVE ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SINGER REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS NINE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN I AM FORTY
SEVEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY MISTER QUIRK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY BY SOME WE RIVER WALDRON
APPERLEY THE JUVENILE SO MAKING
APPROPRIATION ARE FOR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB.
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SPAN STATE
FUNDED REENTRY IN REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES TO FORMALLY AND COARSER
INCARCERATED YOUTH IT IS BACK UP
FROM THE SENATE AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORD IN.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON ITEMS FORTY
NINE AND FIFTY MOVING TO ITEM
FIFTY ONE AB TWENTY NINE FIFTEEN
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
FIFTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
CABALLERO AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAVE YOUR YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THE AMENDMENTS MAINTAIN THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND AMENDED
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
UNDER THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CODE.
THE BELL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON TO
KERN.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION MISTER
CORPUS OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO
KNOW ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS AND RETAIN ON ITEM.
FIFTY TWO MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY
THREE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO
MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SUPERBOWL TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALY ANOTHER SNACK LIKE A PIECE
ALSO TRAINING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DAILY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
I CREATE A TRAINING COURSE ON
HOW TO RESPOND TO CHILD VICTIMS
OF COMMERCIAL SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING IN NATURE.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
FOOD IS OUR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
FIFTY FOUR A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY
TWO MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTY EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AN ACCOLADE PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
HOW THIS BILL THAT WOULD PROTECT
HOME CARE PROVIDERS --
FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT I GIVE
THEM A WAY TO COMPLAIN IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
ONE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM FIFTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY SIX AB SIX
AND NINETY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN
BY SIMPLY RIVER FONG NOT WILLING
TO VEHICLES [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG.
I THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX NINETY SEVEN
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOR MINOR TECHNICAL
NATURE THIS BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
HELP OUR AMBULANCE SERVICES TO
RESPOND TO BRIDGE THE BECAUSE
WITHOUT UNNECESSARY COSTS
DELAYS.
AS YOU SEE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND ZERO NO VOTES RESPECT WE ASK
WHEN I VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER CERVANTES
ANOTHER SNACK LATER CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX FOR
CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT SURVIVORS
BIKES EXPEDITING THE PROSECUTION
OF SERIAL FENCES OF SEXUAL
BATTERY AND UNLAWFUL SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WHICH IS COMMONLY
KNOWN AS STATUTORY RAPE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ACT CHAPTER
YOU KNOW LANGUAGE TO RESOLVE A
CONFLICT WITH SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES SO
FAR IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS%
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS A WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK AND FILE ORDER TIED
IN FIFTY FIVE AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
ANOTHER'S NATALIE VEHICLES IN
THE CLEARLY USES IT ERUPTS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
HOWEVER FRAZIER MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE WHICH HELPS TO ADVANCE
STREAMLINED BUSINESS PARTNER
PROGRAMS WITH THE DMV IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE TO CLARIFY
TRANSPORTATION TROUT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND ADDED AN
URGENCY BECAUSE THE BILL PASSED
THE HOUSE UNANIMOUSLY IN THE HAS
RECEIVED OR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR THANK YOU
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS BROUGH WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE WHICH REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
FRAZIER MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING BACK UP FILE ORDER TO
ITEM FIFTY NINE AB NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSUMING NO NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMAN MALONE
OTHERS AND ACCOLADES FIREARMS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MINUTE BENEFIT
REMEMBERS AB NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT RESTRICTS.
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS RISKS AT HARM
REVERSING THEMSELVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN [inaudible]
MOVING.
WEAVING TO ITEM SIXTY AB TWENTY
THIRTY MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSUMING WILL TWENTY
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON
ACCOLADE CAO WORKS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY THIRTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AB TWENTY THIRTY
WE'LL MAKE SURE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITY IDENTIFIED AND
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE PROPER
SERVICES WERE PARTICIPATING.
IN THE CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
THE KIDS ALSO KNOWN AS CAL
WORKS.
AB TWENTY THIRTY HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
THIS IN MIND IT WAS PRESS
NIVEAU.
THANK YOU SEEING THE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES BY SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY ONE AB
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY RULE TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
KALRA AN ACCOLADE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA.
THINK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SENATE I MISSED AB TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR DELETE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEVELOP TRAINING GUIDELINES FOR
TRANSIT EMPLOYEES TO UNDERGO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AWARENESS
TRAINING AND INSTEAD.
REQUIRE TRANSIT ENTITIES PROVIDE
AT LEAST TWENTY MINUTES OF
TRAINING.
AMENDMENT SPECIFY WHAT TOPICS
SHOULD BE COVERED AND WHAT MAY
BE INCLUDED INFORMATION AND
MATURE EARLY MATERIAL USED BY
SUCCESSFUL TRANSIT.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROGRAMS ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER REPORTED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE COUNTRY
AND MANY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE HIDDEN IN PLAIN
SIGHT ALONG LARGE STATES
TRANSPORTATION ROUTES.
OF AN INFRASTRUCTURE AB TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR EQUIPS THOSE TRANSIT
OPERATORS AND EMPLOYEES ON THE
FRONTLINE OF DEFENSE WITH THE
PROPER TRAINING ON THE SIGNS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
BY DOING SO SUSPECTED ACTS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CAN BE PROPERLY
REPORTED AND IF NEEDED ACTED
UPON BY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PREVENT FURTHER HARM TO THE
VICTIM.
THE BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND SUPPORTED
BY CHANCE STATE MY TRANSIT
AGENCIES AND ASSOCIATIONS
INCLUDING.
CALVET ENTRANCE ASSOCIATION
CAPITAL QUARTERS JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY CALTRAIN BEACH CA AND
REAL PACK ABOUT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT A
CONCURRENCE WAS SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE COURT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
WHO IS OUR TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
TWENTY FIFTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME EVIL TWENTY FIFTY BY SOME
REMEMBER CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY
THE SMALL ONE SYSTEM SMALL
SYSTEM WATER AUTHORITIES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN EUROPE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIFTY WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
ITEM SIXTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB
TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE MISTER COR
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS
SOME EVER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE WILSHIRE
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF MINERS
WHO HAVE PRE REGISTERED TO VOTE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT A CO AUTHOR
AND CHATTERING AT LANGUAGE TO
HAVE MORE TO COME.
LIKE OURS HAS AFFECT THAT HAVE.
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
OR PLEASE OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEM SIXTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY SIX AB.
TWENTY TWO NINETY TO NINETY NINE
MR CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER KANSEN CHU
ACCOLADE THE MEDICO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO SACRAMENTO SPEAKER AB TWENTY
TWO NIKE NUYS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
THE DEEP AMENDMENTS PROVIDED
EXEMPTION FOR MATERIALS TO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN FIELD TESTED.
AND PROVEN TO MEET STANDARDS AS
SET UP IN MY BILL.
THEY CLARIFIED THAT EACH MANSION
MANAGED CARE PLAN OR TWO YEARS
SO SUBCONTRACTORS.
ONLY NEED TO DO WINE COMEDY HE
REVEALED PURSE THRESHOLD
LANGUAGE.
FINALLY DO YOU AMENDMENTS WILL
SET A DEADLINE FOR WHEN REVIEW
DOCUMENTS SHOULD BE COMPLETED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY THREE OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OH
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
AND I BELIEVE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ MENACE
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE
OR FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE BILL CODIFYING EXISTING
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RELATION BOARD
OR PER.
CASE WAS GIVES PROBE
JURISDICTION OVER.
PEACE OFFICER EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATION DISPUTES.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
MAY FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES
PERFECT RIAZ RIVAL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MCCORKLE CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY
THE VOTES EYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS
THREE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN.
ITEM SIXTY NINE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL BE ANOTHER PERSON
ACTUALLY STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE ON TO PRESENT AB
[inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN WHAT.
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE TODAY A BILL
THAT WILL DESIGNATE A DREAM
RESOURCE LIAISON A CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES.
AND RECOMMEND THAT THE UC'S
COMPLY WE TOOK COST SAVING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO
REMOVE THE MANDATE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
COLLEAGUES ARE DREAMERS WILL
GROW UP TO PURSUE A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION TO BETTER
PREPARE THEM TO ENTER INTO
CALIFORNIA'S DEMANDING
WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY KNOWS
WHO WON THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEMS.
ITEM SEVENTY ONE PATH.
P. MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVENTY
ONE AB TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SUPERBOWL
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN BY SOME
WEAVERVILLE JONES SAWYER
ACTUALLY THE COUNTY JAILS.
SOMEONE EVERY JONES SAWYER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIVE
OH SEVEN IS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY
FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN DECEMBER
SENATE MOVED IMPLEMENTATION DATE
TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THE
BILL HAS GONE TO BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
MEMBERS ARE SPECULATIVELY AYE
VOTE.
SEEING A DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
FOOD IS OUR TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVENTY TWO
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY SIMPLY RIVER BLOOM
ANOTHER'S INOCULATE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL SEEKS TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA HABITATS.
MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT IN THE
FACE OF ONGOING CLIMATE CHANGE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE THAT NARROW THE BILL THAT
THIS BODY PREVIOUSLY VOTED ON
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS BROUGH.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
MISTER BLOOM MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SO WE WILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE PEOPLE
HEALTH.
MISTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M PROUD TO JOINT
AUTHORED AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE WITH OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
LONG BEACH WHO AUTHORED
LEGISLATION REQUIRING SCHOOLS
THAT SERVE STUDENTS.
IN GRADE SEVEN TO TWELVE TO
ADOPT POLICIES ON PUPIL SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND BEFORE THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN SCHOOL YEAR.
SENATE AMENDMENTS BUILT UPON
THIS LEGISLATION BY REQUIRING
THE SCHOOLS TO REVIEW THEIR
POLICIES ON PEOPLE SUICIDE
PREVENTION AT MINIMUM EVERY
FIFTH YEAR AND IF NECESSARY. TO
UPDATE THEIR POLICIES.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE WOULD
ENSURE THAT THESE POLICIES
REMAIN RELEVANT AND CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS PUPIL SUICIDE PREVENTION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MICHAEL CLOSED THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TO MISTER
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TO BUY SOME
REMEMBER QUIRK ACT RELATING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
BOB THANK YOU SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY TWO WILL IMPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM.
SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVED
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE PORT
FREEZE.
AND BROUGHT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OF THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE.
HEARD IN.
MOVING ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AN ACCOLADE
HEALTHCARE SERVICE PLAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER A BEAT
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOURS BACK A
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT MANAGE
HEALTH CARE.
AT LEAST ANNUALLY REVIEW
PROVIDER COMPLAINTS THAT A
HEALTH PLAN SERVICE AS UNDERPAID
FAILED TO PAY PROVIDERS FOR
THEIR SERVICES.
IF EVIDENCE OF A PATTERN IS
IDENTIFIED THE BILL GAVE DIEM
AGE SEE THE DISCRETION TO
CONDUCT AN AUDIT OR TAKEN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY FOUR SEEING
THAT NO REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHOSE ARTICLE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ON TALLY
THE VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THAT THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THERE AND
OTHERS NOT LIKE SEISMIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HIS
ARYAN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE WILL
REQUIRE BUILDING DEPARTMENTS AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO CREATE AN
INVENTORY OF POTENTIALLY.
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION AND
SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE INVENTORY SENATE
AMENDMENTS MODIFIED THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND MADE EXEMPTIONS FOR
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALREADY HAVE
LOCAL INVENTORYING ORDINANCES.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
AND MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK
IN FILE ORDER.
DIED IN FORTY NINE E. BE.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY NINE BY SOME THE RIVER
WOULD NOT LET THE HEALING ARTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
THINK THAT A SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SEVEN NINE TWENTY SEVENTY NINES
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE REQUIRES A
BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO ELECTRONIC
TRANSMISSION WILL BE WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR ALL PRESCRIPTIONS.
THE AMENDMENTS ACCEPTED AND
ACCEPTED IN THE SENATE
ESSENTIALLY PROVIDE SPECIFIC
EVENT EXEMPTIONS FOR EMERGENCY
ROOM PHYSICIANS AND HOSPITAL
URGENT CARE SETTINGS.
EXEMPT HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS
FROM PRESCRIBED E. PRESCRIBING.
WOULD WIN DISCOVER INDIVIDUALS
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THINK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE AND
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FROM
SANTA ROSA FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
WELL I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
MEASURE.
THAT I HOPE WE CAN WORK TO
ADDRESS.
I BELIEVE THAT WHILE IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE
MODERNIZING OUR TECHNOLOGY IN
THE MEDICAL FIELD THAT WE DO NOT
BEGIN TO IMPOSE UNDUE HARDSHIPS.
AND BURDENS ON OTHERS.
THERE ARE MANY VALUABLE AND
RESPECTED MEMBERSOF OUR MEDICAL
PRACTICE WHO HAVE BEEN IN
INDIVIDUAL PRACTICE FOR DECADES
AND I'VE BEEN SERVING PARTS OF
OUR STATE WHERE WE DIRECTLY NEED
MEDICAL SUPPORT.
IN THE CASE OF BE PRESCRIBING I
HOPE THAT THESE PER TECH
PRACTITIONERS WILL NOT END UP
FACING CHALLENGES IN
TRANSITIONING OVER TO A
COMPLETELY NEW SYSTEM.
OF ELECTRONIC PRESCRIBING.
I HOPE TO MONITOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD AND ASK THE
AUTHOR IN THOSE IN THIS HOUSE TO
DO THE SAME.
SO THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
CREATING BARRIERS TO ACCESS AND
DELAYS IN CARE DUE TO OUR NEED
TO MODERNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MENACE
BIGGER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL --
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT.
MANY PHYSICIANS INCLUDING MY
BROTHER HAVE UNREADABLE HAND
WRITING IT WOULD ALSO HELP TO
HAVE THIS ONLINE IN THAT IT'S ON
A MODERNIZING AND STREAMLINING
AND COULD PREVENT SOME AREAS
HERE TONIGHT VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
YES THERE'S A ARM.
PROBLEM HERE AS FAR AS
IMPLEMENTING THE SOFTWARE AND
THE ELECTRONIC GONNA END OF IT.
D. M. V. HAS BEEN TRYING TO
UPGRADE THEIR OF SOFTWARE FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND IT FAILED MANY.
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES HAVE TRIED
TO UPGRADE THEIR COMPUTER
ASSISTED DISPATCH SYSTEMS AND
MANY MANY OTHER TECHNOLOGICAL.
AND PROGRAMMING SYSTEMS.
HERE WE ARE GIVING THEM.
VERY LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME. TO
COME UP WITH THE SYSTEMS.
AND WE'RE JUST ORDERING THEM.
TO I STRONGLY RECOMMEND A NO
VOTE.
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNICALITIES OF
PROGRAMMING.
AND FOLLOW UP THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK WE ACTUALLY GIVE THANK
YOU PICKING MINUTE SPEAKER I
THINK REXY GIVING PLENTY OF TIME
WE'RE GIVING FOR YEARS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND AND TRUST ME
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET THE DMV
DO THIS --
THESE ARE PRIVATE OF PRACTICES
THAT WILL ACTUALLY DO THIS THEY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO DO THIS AND
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW.
WE SEE A LOT OF PHYSICIANS ARE
READY DOING THIS WE'RE TRYING TO
CAPTURE EVERYONE IN THE SYSTEM.
WE THINK I THINK IT'S GOOD
PRACTICE FOR EVERYONE THE MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE AND I THINK THE
TIME HAS COME.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ESTHER CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE FIVE NO.
TO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT OF
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR MISTER CLERK
FISHERIES.
SO WE WILL TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD
OTHER SNACK LATER HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CONTRACTS WITH FOR
PROFIT HEALTH PLANS TO CONTAIN A
PROVISION THAT AUTHORIZES
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
TERMINATE ITS MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLAN CONTRACTS EITHER
BECAUSE OF ANTI COMPETITIVE
CONTACT CONDUCT OR NON
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MEDICAL LOSS
RATIO REQUIREMENTS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT
THE FOR PROFIT HEALTH PLAN THAT
VIOLATES EXISTING ANTI
COMPETITIVE AND AND MEDICAL LOSS
RATIO REQUIREMENTS FOR
POTENTIALLY A MONETARY GAIN.
ARE CONTRACTUALLY OBLIGATED TO
BE A TO BE ACCOUNTABLE MOVING
FORWARD SUCH SHOULD D. EIGHT CF
DETERMINE THAT THE VIOLATING
HEALTH PLAN IS NECESSARY. TO
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE BENEFIT YOUR
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE CARE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
ONE KNOWS TEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARK CONCLUDE IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME EVIL TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE VICE LIVERPOOL WE ANOTHER
PERSON ACRYLATE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. SEVEN NEVER
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE ON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENT SURVEY A BILL THAT
WILL HELP INSURE OUR LACTATING
STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
BASIC NEEDS NECESSARY. TO
ACHIEVE ACADEMIC SUCCESS WE TOOK
COST SAVING AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE TO REQUIRE THE
INSTALLATION OF A I THINK UPON
NEW CONSTRUCTION IN THE EVENT OF
THE REPLAY OF REPLACEMENT.
EXPANSION OR RENOVATION OF
CAMPUS COSTING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LOCAL CLOSER RULING TALLY THE
VOTES AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY TO MISTER
COURT PLEASE HURRY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AND OTHERS
ARE NOT WILLING TO RECALL OF
SINCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY TWO PROVIDES
PROSECUTORS ANOTHER TOWARD THEIR
TOOL BOX TO REDUCE DENTIST FOR
DEFENDANTS THAT THEY HAVE THEY
BELIEVE.
HAVE THE POTENTIAL FOR
REHABILITATION.
SENATE AMENDMENT SIMPLIFIED THE
PARAMETERS OF THE PROSECUTOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I'VE RECALL EVERY SENATE TO
PROVIDE A CHAPTER EIGHT CONFLICT
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY ONE
NO SIXTEEN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO JUVENILES.
SOME MEMBER BOOM THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY AND
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL WOULD PERMIT INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE PREVIOUSLY BEEN GRANTED
ACCESS.
BY THE JUVENILE COURT TO INSPECT
AND RECEIVE COPIES OF CASE FILES
FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PARTICIPATING IN AN APPEAL.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE OF
THANK YOU SEEING THE NO
DISCUSSION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM.
EIGHTY A. B. TEN SIXTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TEND SIXTY FIVE BY
SIMPLY RIVER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO PASS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE CREATES A NEW CRIME
AND PENALTIES FOR ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT WHICH HAS AFFECTED
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
NOT ONLY DID HIS BILL CREATE A
NEW ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
STATUE PUNISHABLE WITH A WAFFLER
RECENT AMENDMENTS GREAT RISK
BASED REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
THAT WILL DRIVE DOWN.
RECIDIVISM INCARCERATION.
SUCH PROGRAMS ARE CENTRAL TO
ENSURE WE DON'T INCARCERATE
OFFENDERS WHO ARE EFFECTIVELY
WHO HAVE A FAMILY SERVED.
BY REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
DISABILITY DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY SEVERELY IMPACTED
BY SOPHISTICATED ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT BY IDENTIFYING
THOSE WHO HAVE POTENTIAL RISK TO
BE. TO RE OFFEND AND PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE SUPER BROAD
COALITION FOR BUSINESS LABOR AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. TO BUILD THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CORPORATE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
STIR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
ONE NO.
THREE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEM EIGHTY ONE WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN.
ITEM EIGHTY TWO E. B. THIRTY
EIGHT MISTER QUIRK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY EIGHT BY SOME
LIBERAL MARK STONE IMMACULATELY
STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY EIGHT IS A
IMPLEMENTATION BILL FOLLOWING
THE STUDENT SERVICING ACT.
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE LANDMARK LAW.
REQUIRES THE DV O. TO ACTUALLY
LICENSE STUDENT LOAN SERVICERS
THAT WE GET A HANDLE ON THIS
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF DEBT
THAT OUR STUDENTS AND FORMER
STUDENTS ARE CARRYING OUT INTO
THE ECONOMY.
THEY STILL NOT CERTAIN THING ACT
TOOK EFFECT JULY ONE OF THIS
YEAR BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT PROVIDES TERM.
TECHNICAL CHANGES SO THAT THE
DVR CAN IMPLEMENT THIS BILL IT
ALSO EXAMS GUARANTEE
ORGANIZATIONS AND DEBT
COLLECTORS FROM THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE THEY WERE
NOT.
THE ONES THAT THAT WE WERE
REALLY NEEDING TO LICENSE SO
WITH THAT THOSE WERE THAT WHAT
THE SENATE MET LOT OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS DO I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN THOSE AND
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SINGLE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
THE CORPORATE OPEN THE MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES HIGHS FORTY
TWO KNOWS NINETEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY FIVE
BY SOME MEMORABLE WOULD NOT
BELIEVE HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD THANK YOU
MANY SPEAKER MEMBER AB FIVE
NINETY FIVE STRENGTH THIS
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE
IS OVERSIGHT OVER HEALTH PLAN
MERGERS SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED
PROVISIONS TO HELP DEFINE MAJOR
TRANSACTIONS IN WHICH THE STATE
REGULATOR.
MUST ATTAIN MUST OBTAIN AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS OF THE
IMPACT OF THE TRANSACTION ON
ENROLLEES.
AND THE STABILITY OF THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND A
PUBLIC MEETING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO GO?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FORTY TWO NO SEVENTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN.
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN MISTER
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY FORTY SEVEN BY SOME WE
WERE WRONG.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
ANOTHER VEHEMENTLY SCHOOL
SAFETY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RICE PRESENT
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH
IS BACKROOM CONCURRENCE.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN OR
CHOIR SCHOOLS DEVELOP SAFETY
PROCEDURES FOR VIOLENT INCIDENTS
ON OR NEAR SCHOOL GROUNDS SUCH
AS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
RESPECT ME OUT FOR OUR VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN I
AM EIGHTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT MISTER COURT
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
BY SOME REMEMBER CHAO AN
ACCOLADE OF DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SO SENATE AMENDMENTS
DELAYED THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BILL.
UNTIL JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SEEING THAT NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE COURT
PLEASE OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
I TO MEDIATE PASS AND RETAIN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP FILE ITEM. EIGHTY NINE
FIVE EIGHTY NINE AB.
TWENTY TO THIRTY BY MISTER
BERMAN CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY CIVIL ACTIONS
[inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY A BILL TO
CREATE GREATER EFFICIENCY IN
CIVIL LITIGATION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WOULD EXTEND
THE TIME FRAME WITHIN WHICH
COURTS ARE REQUIRED TO RULE ON
MOTION CERTAIN POST TRIAL
MOTIONS.
THESE CHANGES ARE NEITHER
RADICAL NOR CONTROVERSIAL BUT IT
WILL PROVIDE BENEFIT TO THE
COURTS AND PARTIES TO LITIGATION
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL UP THE ROLL-ON VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
IN TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY NINE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND VIOLATE IN.
NINETY IS AB TWENTY TO FORTY
SEVEN COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN BY SIMPLY NEVER GIPSON
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE FOSTER
YOU [inaudible]
MISTER GIPSON.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO FORTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE.
THANK YOU MUCH GIPSON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AND I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE IS AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMON
INACCURATE A STATE GOVERNMENT.
THIS THE MONTH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT AND WILL
CREATE A CENTRALIZED.
DATABASE OF ALL STATE GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
BY MAKING CALIFORNIA GRANTS
ACCESSIBLE AND TRANSPARENT WE
CAN ASSURE ALL INTERESTED
ENTITIES HAVE A FAIR SHOT AT
STATE FUNDING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK MS AMONG SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
SURE CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN ACR
TWO SEVENTY SIX SOLACE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE.
CLERK WILL KNOW.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
AND WITHDRAW S. B. A TWENTY ONE
JACKSON.
AND ORDER THE BILL BACK ON THE
THE THIRD READING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SIX TO EIGHT OF OUR NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR A.
B.. THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE GRAY
AND ACR TWO SEVENTY TWO KILEY ON
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH AT
THIRTY A. M..
IN ROOM.
FOUR FORTY SEVEN AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE REQUESTS GRANTED
AM PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SEVEN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER S. B. TWELVE
FORTY NINE GALGIANI TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER WE ARE
FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE BY MISTER LACKEY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SO WE WILL TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE
BY SOME WEAVERVILLE LACKEY AND I
BELIEVE THE CAMPUS MISTER
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY TWO OF BACK. FOR
CONCURRENT TO PROVIDES GUIDES
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN THEY COUNTER CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTOR DELIVERY DRIVER IN
OTHER WORDS?
IT WILL BLUNT ILLEGAL ACTORS AND
CLEAR UP THE LEGAL HAZE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WAS THERE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARKE WELL CLOSER ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS OUR CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS OF PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM WE SENDING MY PREVIOUS
REFERRAL OF SP TEN FIFTY FOUR
HERTZBERG. TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND I AM ORDERING THE
BILL BACK TO THE THIRD
[inaudible]
READING FILE.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER ON
THE CONCURRENCE FILE THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
NINETY THREE AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY ONE COOPERATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO NINETY
ONE BY SOME WEAVERVILLE DAVID
SHE WOULD ACT LIKE A SCHOOL
SAFETY.
MISTER KEW EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
ONE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE FOR
THIS BILL TO HELP SCHOOLS DEAL
WITH BULLYING AND HARASSMENT IN
OUR SCHOOLS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
TO ENSURE THAT TERMS AND
DEFINITIONS ARE CONSISTENT
THROUGHOUT THE BILL I APPRECIATE
THE OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS FLOOR AND IN THE
SENATE.
AND THIS BILLS NOT HAD ANY NO
VOTES SO FAR RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
SCENE NOW DISCUSS HER DEBATE ON
THE ON VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
AND TELL THEM WHAT I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
BY MISTER BONTA.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMORABLE BONTA
NATALIE THE TAXATION.
I SHOULD BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
BILL UNDERWENT CHAPTER RING OUT.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE TO
PREVENT CONFLICTS WITH OTHER
LEGISLATIVE MEASURES IT WAS ON
CONSENT IN ASSEMBLY REVENUE
ATTACKS TAXATION COMMITTEE AND
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR HAS RECEIVED
ZERO NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK MISS BONTA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE.
HOWEVER I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
EMERSON FILE ORDER WE ARE FILE
ITEM.
NINETY FOUR AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE BY MISS RATES CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMORY AS AN
ACCOLADE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES [inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE --
WOULD SENATE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS HAVE NARROWED THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL TO NOW COLLECT
DATA ON EMT LICENSING.
CURRENTLY THERE IS A LACK OF
DATA IN REGARDS TO DENIALS THREE
EMPTY LICENSES AND THE REASONING
BEHIND THEM.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO FILL IN
THOSE GAPS IN ADDRESS ISSUES
WITH ACCURACY AND ENSURE THE
PEOPLE RE ENTERING THE WORKFORCE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
MAKING HIS RENTS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT.
ICE FOUR KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE
IS AB TWENTY TWO NINETY EIGHT
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME WE'VE EVER CHAO
ACT LIKE THE FAMILY LAW
[inaudible]
MR CHOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY TO NINETY
EIGHT IS BACK ON CONCURRENT SO
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BILL ARE
MINOR AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED ZERO OF ZERO NO VOTES A
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS CHOW NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI OF ICE FORTY
NINE KNOWS SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND
MEMBERS.
ARE MOVING BACK IN THE
CONCURRENCE FILE THE FLE ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB FOR TWENTY SEVEN
COOPERATE.
SO WE GO FOR TWENTY SEVEN BY
SOME WE WERE MURATSUCHI AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE AEROSPACE.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FOUR TO SEVEN WELL
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE COMMISSION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
THE COMMISSION WILL BE ENTIRELY
PRIVATELY FUNDING.
NO NO VOTES IN BOTH HOUSES NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO I'M SORRY MISTER
LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
YES SURF COURSE I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BEFORE --
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE
WERE --
PRESENTING THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
COULD CONTINUES TO LEAD AN
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION.
AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN
MY DISTRICT.
WHERE ALL SPACES BECOME THE
HEART OF THE ANNUAL VALLEY?
THIS BILL DEMONSTRATES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
BEING.
THE LEADER IN AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
COMPETITION RIGHT NOW SO WE
NEED.
TO KEEP THE BALL MOVING AND I'VE
HEARD YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
[inaudible]
CARP LIBERALS.
WHO'S THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY NINE
THOSE ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE FILE ITEM NINE AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY FIVE BY MR THURMAN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME APRIL FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SOME REPAIRMEN THAT RELATE TO
EMPLOYMENT DECLARE THE UC THEIR
OF ITS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
[inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARISE RESENT AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
FIVE FOR CONCURRENCE THIS IS A
FOLLOW UP BUILT TO LAST YEAR
SEVENTEEN ONE WHICH ENSURES THAT
WORKERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY OR PAY THEIR WAGES ARE
PAID ON TIME --
THIS THAT MEASURE REPRESENTS AN
AGREEMENT REACHED BY BUILDERS
AND BY A LABOR ORGANIZATIONS AND
PROVIDING OF BOTH THE EMPLOYEES
AND EMPLOYERS WITH THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO ENSURE
THAT ALL WORKERS ARE PAID
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I THINK THIS THURMOND SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
HE'S OUT OF A LITTLE MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY ON MEMBERS SO.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
PARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
CALVET I SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY EYES SEVENTY NO.
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
ARE CONCURRENT.
BACK IN THE REGULAR FILE ORDER.
WE ARE AT AB PARMI WE'RE FILE
ITEM.
NINETY SIX AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE FIFTY
BY SIMPLY RIVER OBERNOLTE AN
ACCOLADE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
SURE OBERNOLTE THANK MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
STATE COMPTROLLER UPDATES
ACCOUNTING AND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES FOR THE STATE'S
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY PROGRAM
THAT'LL MAKE MANAGEMENT OF THE
PROGRAM MORE EFFICIENT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OF THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS THEIR VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SEND AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS HER MOVING BACK AND THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER. FIFTY
FIFTY THIS IS AB [inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN BY SOME REMEMBER HOLD A
MONOPOLY INTO EMPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
MISTER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINETEEN IS BACK IN THIS SIMPLY
AYE CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES UNIVERSAL
CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFICALLY THE
BUNCH CENTER FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT UCLA. TO
CONDUCT A BAN ON ALL STUDY ON
THE DIVERSITY OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND EMPLOYEES OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH TECH COMPANIES.
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE PROGRAMS
AND BEST PRACTICES THAT SEEK TO
DIVERSIFY THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKFORCE.
THE DISNEY TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
WILL CREATE A WORKING GROUP TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE REPORT AT A
PERSPECTIVE.
PERSPECTIVES OF STUDENTS
RESEARCHERS AND INDUSTRY
LEADERS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP US DETERMINE
WHAT IS NEEDED TO INCREASE.
DIVERSE HIRING AND THE FASTEST
GROWING INDUSTRY TO ENSURE ALL
COMMUNITIES.
ARE CONSIDERED WHICH PROVIDES
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDING.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL I AM.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU ABOUT EYES FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TWENTY TWO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT IN BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
NINETY SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINETY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN BY SOME WOMEN WHO WOULD
NOW THERE'S AN ACCOLADE TO MEDI
CAL [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES APARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES CONTRACTS FOR WITH FOR
PROFIT HEALTH PLANS TO CONTAIN A
PROVISION AUTHORIZED THE EIGHT
CS. TO TERMINATE AS MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLAN CONTRACTS
EITHER BECAUSE OF AN ANTI
COMPETITIVE CONDUCT OR
NONCOMPLIANCE WITH MEDICAL LOSS
RATIO.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT
THE FOR PROFIT PLANS A VIOLATE
THESE EXISTING ANTI COMPETITIVE
AND NOW OUR REQUIREMENTS FOR
POTENTIALLY A MONETARY GAIN A
CONTRACTUAL LOCK WE GET IT.
ACCOUNTABLE MOVING FORWARD
SHOULD DHC HAS DETERMINED THAT
THE PLAN IS THAT IS THE HEALTH
VIOLATING.
HEALTH PLAN IS NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE BENEFICIARY
ACCESS I RESPECT BASS FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
I THINK THAT WOULD SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROMANCE TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
WE'RE GOING.
TO THINK YOU WERE GOING TO PASS
A RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE HUNDRED AB. TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY TWO BY MISTER BERMAN CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS
[inaudible]
MR MURRAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE ON SENATE
AMENDMENTS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO ESTABLISH A BALLOT DESIGN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
BALLOT DESIGN AND READABILITY OF
BALLOT INSTRUCTIONS AS SPECIFIED
THIS BILL WAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN RESERVE AND HAS RECEIVED NARY
A NO VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN PLEASE
STOP COPYING MISTER DALY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TYLER I SIXTY THREE KNOWS TO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK AND TAKE A FILE ITEM.
NINETY SEVEN THE FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY TWO BY SIMPLY RIVER
SANTIAGO ACKLEY TO TOWING IT
SORT OF VEHICLES [inaudible]
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
THIS BILL COMES BACK WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE CLARIFYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON FILE
BUT THEY COMMIT SANTIAGO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS FUNDS ARE THE ALMA
BRIDGE VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT AND MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
[inaudible]
MS FRIEDMAN'S ITEMS
.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE TO TAKE
A FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY ONE FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE IS A. B..
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO FIND THE
FUTURE.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO ENERGY.
MISS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A. B. THIRTY TO THIRTY
TWO IS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
A FINAL FORM VOTE A. B. THIRTY
TO THIRTY TWO WAS NOT AMENDED IN
THE SENATE AND APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY WITH THE EXACT SAME
LANGUAGES WHEN IT PASSED THIS
HOUSE.
ON MAY THIRTY FIRST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TO ITS
FINAL FORM.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLAND TELEVOTE EYES.
FORTY THREE NOSE TWENTY ONE THE
SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WANT TO MOVE YOU TAKE A
MISS FRIEDMAN'S OTHER ITEM THAT
IS PENDING THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN THIS IS AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX SIXTY
THREE BY SOME MEMORY BUT OTHERS
AND ACT LIKE A TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
[inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
IF YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE WILL CREATE
PARITY IN THE LAW FOR ALL
REGISTERED DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THE
ORIGINALLY REGISTERED.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL AND SIMPLY OUT OF
A CO AUTHOR.
NO ONE SHOULD BE AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOME AS A RESULT OF
THE DEATH OF A PARTNER.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE CLOSES
IN UNINTENDED LOOPHOLE ENSURED
THAT ALL COUPLES HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO BENEFITS INCLUDING TAX
RELIEF I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
NAME IS FRIEDMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS LED TO SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI THE VOTE I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER
MEMBERS WERE PASSING AND
RETAINING ON FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED PARTY MEMBERS WHERE
THEY TOOK UP FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED WHEN TO PASS RETAIN
A FILE ITEM ONE OLD.
ONE THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
ONE NO.
TO IS FILE ITEM. ONE OUT TO AB
TWENTY SIX OF TO THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX OH TO
BUY SOME WE WERE MCCARTY AN
ACCOLADE HOMELESS YOU.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
RELATE TO EMERGENCY HOUSING
SERVICES FOR OUR YOUTH IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ASPIRATE.
THING IS MCCARTY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF
BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
.
IS FILE ITEM. ONE OF THREE AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
CORPORATE.
SOME A BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT BY SOME MIRACLE OF ONE
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE THE
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT WILL
ESTABLISH A BLOCKCHAIN WORKING
GROUP TO STUDY THE USES OF RISKS
AND BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH.
AND THE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS OF
THE USE A BLOCKCHAIN BY STATE
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA BASED
BUSINESSES SENATE AMENDMENTS
MAKE MINOR CHANGES TO THE
DEFINITION OF BLOCKCHAIN
REQUIRED THAT THE SECRETARY OF
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY. TO
DESIGNATE A CHAIRPERSON OF THE
WORKING GROUP I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
CLARKE WELL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALTERNATIVE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NOSE ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE OF FOUR'S AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX NINETY
ONE BY SOME MEMORABLE JONES
SAWYER LIKELY THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS YEAR JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY ONE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKE IT IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL AND EXTENDED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE.
A. B. TWENTY SIX DIED WHEN IT'S
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
AYE VOTE.
NAMES JONES WHERE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE THOUGH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN CORPORATE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI ANOTHER WAS AN
ACCOLADE PESTICIDES MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION TO SUBMIT A
REPORT.
INCOME ON THE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE HELP THE SCHOOLS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SAID AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE SENATE
FLOOR.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLE AND TELL I HAVE
EYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS.
NINE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE NO.
SIX AB [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE OH EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE OH
WAIT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE TIRE
RECYCLING [inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE RESENT AB
TWENTY NINE OH WAIT A BILL WHICH
WOULD HELP CREATE A MARKET FOR
THE FORTY FOUR MILLION USED
TIRES.
THAT CALIFORNIANS GENERATE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
ILLEGALLY DUMPED TIRES POSE A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE.
AND LARGE ABANDONED TIRE PILES
HAVE RESULTED IN WEEKS LONG
FIRES.
IN ORDER TO SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE TIRE RECYCLING AB
TWENTY NINE OH WAY WOULD CREATE
THE TIRE RECYCLING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM EMPLOYING A PROVEN MODEL
OF PERFORMANCE BASED INCENTIVE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE USE.
OF HER EYES PAVEMENT AND OTHER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS MADE FROM USED
TIRES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
FAMOUS BERMAN SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARPEL OF THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY EIGHT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT AND PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN FILE ITEM
ONE NO.
EIGHT IS AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER WEBER
ACCOLADE TO EVIDENCE.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY HAPPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS HAVE
NARROWED THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
PROVIDING THAT WHEN A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY INTENDS TO DISPOSE OF
BIOLOGICAL MATERIAL.
THE PERSON IS CURRENTLY SERVING
A TERM OF IMPRISONMENT THE
NOTIFICATION WILL BE SENT TO THE
CURRENT LOCATION WHERE THE
PERSON IS INCARCERATED.
ANY COUNSEL OF RECORD THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE.
THEY CONNECT WEBER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON THE WRIST
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
TELL IT ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE
NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY FOUR WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
.
MISTER MURATSUCHI MOVED TO CALL
MR MERCY CHI REPLACES THE CALL
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN
FILE ITEMS ONE NINE AND ONE TEN
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE ELEVEN AB THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER CALDERON OF
ACCOLADE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTY EIGHTY FIVE WILL
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
EITHER PURSUE A HOMELESS
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM OF THEIR OWN
OR EXPAND ON AN EXISTING.
ONE THE AMENDMENTS TAKING THE
SENATE SPECIFIED THE NUMBER OF
GRANTS THAT MAY BE AWARDED PER
YEAR I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN SENATE
CONCURRENCE.
THEY WAS CALDERON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I FORTY SEVEN NOS.
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
ITEM [inaudible]
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN S. B.. THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE STERN TO THE
UTILITIES.
AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AND ITEM NUMBER THREE NINETY
FIVE S. B. FIVE OF TWO
PORTANTINO TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS BACK AND FILE ORDER THIS
IS FILE ITEM.
ONE TWELVE THEY B. THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN BY MISTER DAVID CHIU
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
EIGHTEEN BY SOME MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS ARE NOT RELATE A
SEXUAL ASSAULT [inaudible]
SHOULD YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTY ONE
RATE CUT BACKLOG IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT A CO AUTHOR
AND ENSURE THAT ANONYMOUS KITS
HELD BY RAPE CRISIS CENTERS WILL
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL.
APPRECIATE THE UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN VOTES IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE FLOORS AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
MEMBERS IN FILE LOWER THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY NINE BY MISS RUBIO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY ONE TWENTY
NINE BY SOME WOMEN WHO RUBIO AN
ACCOLADE THE FIREARMS MISS
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PRESENTING AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY
NINE OH THAT IS BACK. FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL IN
HOUSE PUB ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
TO SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON THE
MORE SERIOUS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES.
MEMBERS YOUR OFFICE IS RECEIVED
AN ARTICLE PUBLISHED BY NPR THAT
STATED HALF OF ALL FEMALE
HOMICIDE VICTIMS ARE KILLED BY
IN THE INTIMATE PARTNERS.
WE MUST DO MORE TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALBOT EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWELVE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON A COUPLE OF ITEMS.
I'M PREPARED TO LIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO THIS IS AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY A
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
AND NOW PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
THREE THIS IS S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
TO THE CORPORAL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE EYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND NOW MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
TO FIFTY ONE THIS IS S. B..
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT AYE AYES.
FORTY ONE NOS.
TWENTY SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE THIRTEEN THIS IS.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FOURTEEN AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY BY MISTER TANG
[inaudible]
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX TWENTY
BY SIMPLY REVERTING ACT RELATING
TO RONALD PASSENGER VEHICLE
TRANSACTIONS MR TANK.
I THINK IT WOULD SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY BACK AKA
CURRENTS THE BILL HELPS RENTAL
CAR COMPASS RESTORED GREAT
RECOVER STOLEN VEHICLES BY
SHORTENING THE WAITING PERIOD TO
TURN ON GPS TRACKING FROM SEVEN
TO THREE DAYS.
AFTER VEHICLE HASN'T BEEN
RETURNED RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
ENGLISH TING SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WERE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB
EIGHTY SEVEN BY MISTER TANG
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER TING ANOTHER FROM
ACCOLADE TO VEHICLES MISTER
TANG.
I THINK IT SPEAKER A. B. I
EIGHTY SEVENTH ON CONCURRENCE
THE BILL ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOUND
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES OPERATING
WITHOUT A VALID PERMIT ON PUBLIC
ROADS.
AND HOLD ON TO THAT VEHICLE TELL
ABOUT PERMIT IS IN PLACE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT NOW.
THEY WISH TING SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
QUIRK WELL CLOSE RURAL TOWN
ABOUT I SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTEEN AB. FIVE FIVE EIGHT
FOR FOR READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
BY SOME WE'VE EVER QUIRK SILVA
ACCOLADE OF VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT
REQUIRES THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO DEVELOP A SUMMARY ON THE
PRODUCTION AND REGISTRATION OF
FLEX FUEL VEHICLES AND E. EIGHTY
FIVE FUEL.
MAKE THAT SUMMARY PUBLIC IN
PROVIDE IT TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL.
PROTECTION AGENCY BY APRIL
FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR POLICY BASED
ON THIS REPORT BY OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
AND PASSED THE SENATE WITH ZERO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WHO IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TELEVOTE AYE.
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN IS AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE CORKERY.
SO WE WILL FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE
BY SOME LEVER WITH BERMAN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE DRINKING WATER
[inaudible]
MISTER THURMOND.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
ARE RICE BUSY AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
NINE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
AT THIS BILL HAS A PROVISION TO
HELP PROTECT DRINKING WATER. TO
PREVENT ANY CROSS CONTAMINATION
--
POLLUTED WATER IN OUR DRINKING
WATER SOURCES.
THE BILL PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON
WHICH CERTIFICATIONS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO PERFORM WORK.
I CHECKED BACK FLOW AND IT
ALLOWS AGENCIES TO REJECT ANY
CERTIFICATION WHERE THERE'S A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN.
ABOUT SAFETY OR QUALITY THESE
MEASURES ARE IN PLACE AND SO
STATE WATER BOARD ISSUES NEW
REGULATIONS AND ULTIMATELY
REDUCES COSTS BY PREVENTING
INSPECTORS FROM HAPPEN TO
MAINTAIN.
MULTIPLE ARMED CERTIFICATE ON
BEHALF OF OUR CONSUMERS AND
THEIR SAFETY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES THURMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS OUT OF THOSE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS.
TWENTY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
TEN AB. ONE EIGHTY SIX BY DR
EGGMAN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
IMMACULATELY CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES [inaudible]
DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE EIGHTY SIX
OVERDOSE PREVENTION CENTERS IS
BACK HERE ON CONCURRENT --
THIS OF THE BILL THAT'S GOT SOME
CONVERSATION GOING AROUND IT WE
HAVE REDUCED IT DOWN TO JUST
INCLUDE SAN FRANCISCO FOUR FOUR
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
D. A.'S ARE DROP THEIR
OPPOSITION MEMBERS WE KNOW WE
HAVE PEOPLE LOSING THEIR LIVES
ON THE STREETS WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS NOT WORKING WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S OVER TWENTY
YEARS OF DATA THAT SUPPORTS
THESE.
AS A HARM REDUCTION PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE TO HELP PEOPLE GET INTO
TREATMENT AND TO SAVE LIVES A
LITTLE BIT LONGER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN MISTER
ALLEN HERE RECOGNIZE QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
HOUSE IS NOT LEGALIZED HEROIN
INJECTIONS ENTERS THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO --
ANSWER MY CLOTHES [inaudible]
THIS ROUND.
ON MY OWN TIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WHAT IS
HAPPENING BEFORE YOU IS THE
DESTRUCTION.
OF VALUES THAT WE HOLD DEAR
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
COUNTRY [inaudible]
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT LEGALIZED
HEROIN INJECTION CENTERS IS A
BAD IDEA AND IT'S NOT JUST A BAD
IDEA IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA.
DON'T LET THE BILL'S AUTHOR AND
THE BILL'S PROPONENTS TRY TO
TELL YOU THIS IS JUST ABOUT
OVERDOSING.
THIS IS ABOUT HAVING LEGALIZED
HEROIN EJECTION CENTERS.
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND IT STARTS THERE.
AND THEN WILL SPREAD TO THE REST
OF THE STATE.
I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THIS
IS HOW IT STARTS.
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN.
THE OPEN DRUG POLICY.
OF MANY MEMBERS ON THIS FOR MANY
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THERE'S MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
THAT ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH PERSONAL DRUG USE.
BUT THE STUDIES ARE CLEAR THIS
STUDY SHOW.
THE HEROIN USE DOES NOT HAVE
GOOD CONSEQUENCES.
AND JUST BECAUSE THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO SANCTION NOT ONE BUT
TO LEGALIZE HEROIN INJECTION
CENTERS IN JULY OF THIS YEAR.
DOESN'T MAKE IT RIGHT DOESN'T
MAKE A GOOD FOR THE COMMUNITIES
AND IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T MAKE IT
LEGAL.
THESE ARE STILL ILLEGALLY
OPERATED SITES WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE SANCTIONED BY CITY
REGULATION OR STATE LAW.
SAY NO TO HEAR AN EJECTION
CENTERS IN SAN FRANCISCO SEE
NOTE HERE INJECTION CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SAY NO TO THIS
BILL.
MS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
EIGHTY SIX WE ALL COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE OAK OPIATE EPIDEMIC BUT YET
WE WANT --
OTHER PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT EPIDEMIC SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
SPED UP.
I SPOKE TO THE MAYOR PERSONALLY
AND SHE SAID IF YOU GUYS DON'T
WANT TO DO THIS.
AND OTHER COUNTIES I'M WILLING
TO GIVE IT A TRY SHE LOST HER
SISTER TO AN OVERDOSE AND SHE
SAID THAT SHE IS WILLING TO BE
THE GUINEA PIG FOR THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE 418% OF THE FOLKS THAT
ENTERED THOSE FACILITIES GOT OFF
DRUGS AND SHE IS WILLING TO
STAND UP FOR THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN AND TRY THIS
PROGRAM IT IT WORKS.
WE CAN EXPAND IT TO OTHER PLACES
IN THE IN CALIFORNIA AND IF IT
DOESN'T WORK WILL SCRAP IT AND
START ALL OVER AGAIN.
IF WE TRULY ARE.
VESTED IN SAVING FOLKS FROM
OVERDOSE AND FROM DRUGS WE HAVE
TO TRY SOMETHING WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW IS NOT WORKING.
WE NEED.
TO REALLY STEP UP AND HELP OTHER
FOLKS THAT WANT TO TRY THESE
PROGRAMS SO WITH THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE EIGHTY SIX AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MS MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN --
I CERTAINLY SHARE THE CONCERN
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS WITH RESPECT
TO TO DRUG USE THAN IT IS AN
EPIDEMIC AND IT CERTAINLY IS A
PROBLEM SAN FRANCISCO IF
ANYONE'S BEEN THERE RECENTLY I
THINK THEY COULD SEE THAT FOR
THEMSELVES --
THE ISSUE ISN'T THAT WE WANT.
THAT WE DISAGREE ON PEOPLE AND
YOU'RE SAVING THEM FROM
OVERDOSING THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE
MY CONCERN IS THERE IS THERE'S
NOTHING BAKED INTO THE IN A
SENSE THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
BILL.
THAT --
REQUIRES ANY SORT OF DRUG
TREATMENT SO.
BY HAVING THIS TYPE OF FACILITY
AVAILABLE.
AND REMEMBER PUBLIC RESOURCES
WILL BE USED A MAYBE NOT IN
FUNDING THE PERSONALLY BUT
CERTAINLY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS HAVE TO
COME UP RIGHT TREATMENT BUT IT'S
IT'S ENCOURAGING PROLONGED
[inaudible]
USE AB DRUGS IT'S IT'S SORT OF
PERPETUATING ADDICTION WHICH IS
KIND OF THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE
WANNA DO WE WANT THEM --
TO TO GET OFF OF THESEDRUGS AND
GET THEIR LIVES TURNED AROUND
AND BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND NOT NEED THIS
THIS TYPE OF HELP SO I DON'T SEE
HOW.
OPENING THIS KIND OF CENTER
WHICH MAY KEEP THEM FROM
OVERDOSING AND ULTIMATELY DYING
IT.
WILL STILL KEEP THEM ON DRUGS
AND PARTICULARLY THESE TYPES OF
DRUGS THEY MAY NOT DIE FROM AN
OVERDOSE.
BUT THEY'RE VERY LIKELY GOING TO
DIE FROM OTHER COMPLICATIONS
OTHER HEALTH RELATED
COMPLICATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROLONGED USE OF THESE TYPES OF
DRUGS SO FOR THAT REASON I WOULD
ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK HEAVENS MELENDEZ DOCTOR
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE SCIENCE
FIRMLY DEMONSTRATES THAT THESE
PROGRAMS PREVENT NEEDLESS DEATH
DISEASE AND SUFFERING.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY PUBLISHED
IN THE JOURNAL OF ADDICTION OF
THE PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS IN
VANCOUVER CANADA CANADA.
BRITISH COLUMBIA WHERE 30% MORE
LIKELY TO ENTER DRUG TREATMENT
HAD HAVE HIGHER RATES OF DRUG
TREATMENT COMPLETION.
AND SIMILAR DRUG USERS WHO DID
NOT ATTEND THE PROGRAM AN
ADDICTION SPECIALIST DESCRIBE
THESE OUTCOMES AS ASTOUNDING.
DOWNEY LEE GOOD.
IN ONE OF THE BILL'S POLICY
COMMITTEES HEARINGS THIS YEAR.
WE SHOULD ALLOW SAN FRANCISCO
THE DISCRETION TO PILOT THESE
PROMISING PRACTICES AND GET MORE
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT PROGRAMS
WITH THE GOAL OF TURNING LIVES
AROUND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOOD.
MISTER CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LME FOR
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL --
FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD AND
RESPONDING TO SOME OF THE
OBJECTIONS I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE --
THE THOUGHT AND DELIBERATION.
BOB THERE WAS A SUGGESTION MADE
OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE
ELSINORE THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TREATMENT AND I WOULD LIKE.
TO SUGGEST EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE
SUPERVISE LOCATIONS ARE MEANT TO
HELP GET PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT
IT'S ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS AND INTO A SAFE
LOCATION.
PROVIDING ONE ON ONE CONTACT
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
PROVIDING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT AND
ONTO A BETTER PATH OF LIFE.
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM OTHERS ARE
THIS HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER COUNTRIES IN
CANADA IN AUSTRALIA AND EUROPE
WHO'VE SEEN DROPS IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS HIV AND HEPATITIS C.
TRANSMISSION.
AND GENERAL PUBLIC DISORDER AND
NUISANCE ASSOCIATED WITH DRUGS
GO DOWN AS WELL AS A GREATER
UPTAKE IN DRUG ADDICTION
TREATMENTS ARE THAT IS FAR
BETTER THAN LEAVING PEOPLE ALONE
ON THE STREETS.
OUR CITY HAS ESTIMATED THAT
THESE --
THIS POTENTIAL PILOT COULD SAVE
US MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR IN
MEDICAL COSTS.
AND LET ME SAY THIS WE HAVE
PEOPLE.
NOT JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT
ALL OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE DYING ON OUR STREETS WHO
ARE DYING IN THE STREETS WE NEED
TO TRY SOMETHING ELSE.
AND WITH THAT WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS PILOT PROGRAM SO
THAT WE CAN TEST SAYS AND IF IT
WORKS.
WE CAN SEE ARE THE SAVINGS BUT
OF COURSE THE IMPACT ON HUMAN
LIVES WITH THAT RESPECT WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THEY CAN BE SURE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL DEBATE AND I AND I AM
HEARTENED.
UP BY THE EVOLUTION I THINK THAT
WE'VE ALL EXPERIENCED IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THING WAS THREE YEARS AGO WE
COULDN'T GET A VOTE OUT OF OUR
FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE.
SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE SEEN
COUNTLESS PEOPLE DIE ON THE
STREETS WE'VE SEEN HEPATITIS GO
UP.
RECEIVE HIV GOES UP WE'VE SEEN
ISSUES ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOMELESSNESS A LOT OF THE ILLS
THAT WE SEE ON THE STREETS
CONTINUE TO GO UP.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I HAD THE AYE UNFORTUNATE
EXPERIENCE OF ATTENDING A
FRIEND'S FUNERAL THIS WEEKEND.
THIS WEEK UP CHOOSE FORTY SIX TO
PHD PROFESSOR.
A DIET ON A FAMILY VACATION --
AND IN DURING THE SERVICE.
WE TALK ABOUT HER USE OF HER
DEGREE AND OF TELLING STORIES OF
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE.
OFTENTIMES IN HISTORY BOOKS IT'S
THE FAMOUS PEOPLE IT'S A BRIDGE
IN THAT THE POWERFUL BUT
OFTENTIMES IS NOT THE EVERYDAY
PEOPLE THE SEAMSTRESS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS PEOPLE ARE SERVING OUR
FOOD ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE
UP THE FABRIC OF OUR LIVES OF
OUR WORLD OF OUR SOCIETY.
AND I GUESS WHEN I WAS SITTING
IN THERE I WAS THINKING ABOUT DO
I YOU KNOW DO I DO I DO ENOUGH.
IN THE USE OF MY OWN PRIVILEGE
OF EDUCATION I HAVE [inaudible]
AND PEOPLE.
WHEN I ASKED ABOUT BEFORE ABOUT
GUN SO I HIGH HAPPEN HAVE A
PEACH PHD IN SOCIAL WORK AND
SOCIAL RESEARCH?
WE STUDY SOCIAL PROBLEMS AND
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
SOLVING THESE ISSUES.
I ONE OF THE THINGS AND I KNOW
THAT WE DO IS WE DO WITH
COMPASSION.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE
AND WE SAY THAT EVERY LIFE
MATTERS.
EVERY LIFE MATTERS MEMBER WHO
ARE WE IF WE'RE NOT PASSING LAWS
FOR EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO RISE TO THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL DO I AGREE DRUGS
ARE BAD YES I AGREE BUT DO I
THINK THAT JUST SAYING NO HAS
HELPED.
NO IT HASN'T HELPED MEMBERS AND
WE STILL SEE THE EPIDEMIC WE OWE
IT TO PEOPLE TO GIVE THEM ONE
MORE CHANCE TO GET HELP. ONE
MORE CHANCE TO GET INTO
TREATMENT TO SAVE MONEY TO SAVE
LIVES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE WRONG TIED OUT EYES.
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY FOUR SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND MEMBERS WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT
REMAIN ON CALL.
I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE BY MISTER
FRAZIER.
THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROWLAND HIVE ON I SIXTY
FIVE NO SEVEN ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY FIVE NO SEVEN ON THE
MEASURE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
NOW MEMBERS HAVE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TO FORTY
FOUR S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR MAYOR SU CHI
CARPOOL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO SARAJEVO.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
[inaudible] TWENTY FOUR THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WHICH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY.
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSUMING
CURRENT RESOLUTION TO SEVENTY
NINE BY SOME THE RIVER KALRA
OTHERS RELATIVES PLANT BASED
DIETS.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE WRONG
ENCOUNTER.
THIS IS CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE IN THAILAND I SEVENTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
SINIG CURRENT RESOLUTION TO
EIGHTY ONE I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO REALLY TO I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SUM
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO EIGHTY
THREE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SUM
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO READY.
FOR I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SUM
THE CURRENT RESOLUTION TO SIXTY
THREE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN NINETY THREE I SEVENTY
FIVE KNOWS CITY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY TWO I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO CITY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FORTY
NINE I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO CITY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE FIFTY
FOUR I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
ONE SIXTY THREE I SEVENTY FIVE
NO ZERO CYNIC GRANT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY FOUR I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO CITY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE ELEVEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO.
ZERO MEMBERS --
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS.
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION.
BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO BUDGET
IN FORTY TWO A TWO THIS IS UPON
ADJOURNMENT EDUCATION COMMITTEE
IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
IN THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IS IN
ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AND
APPROPRIATIONS.
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF HUMAN
SERVICES.
IN ROOM.
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN AND THEN
MEETING AT EIGHT PM THIS EVENING
IS THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
S. B. NINE NO.
ONE WHICH WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO OH TWO SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH FLOOR
SESSION.
FROM TEN A. M..
TO SIX P. M. AND THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO DO SOME
VOTE CHANGES.
WHILE WE HAVE THE FLOOR CLEAR OF
CONVERSATION.
MAYES A. B..
MAYES A. B. NINETEEN NINETY TWO
I TO NOT VOTING.
WHO CHANGE MAYES ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ARE TO NOT
VOTE?
DALY AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN
CHANGE FROM YES TO NO.
DALY SO WE WILL TWENTY EIGHT
NINETEEN I TO KNOW.
KILEY AB TWO FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
AYE AYE TO NOT VOTING.
KILEY SO WE WILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN AB TWENTY FIFTY AYE
TO NOW.
MAIENSCHEIN ASSIM LEGAL TWENTY
FIFTY I'D TO KNOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY AB TWO TWO NINE
NINE NODA I AGUIAR-CURRY SO WE
WILL TWENTY THREE NINETY NINE
NOTES I BLOOM AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE I DON'T KNOW.
BLOOM SOME LEGAL TWENTY ONE
FIFTY ONE I'D TO KNOW.
VOEPEL.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AYE AYE TO KNOW.
VOEPEL SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN I'D TO KNOW.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUE WHO
WILL BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISS MELENDEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I RISE TODAY TO
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN A JOINING
IN MEMORY. FOR MY FATHER LA.
LUIZ CARLOS MELENDEZ.
WHO PASSED AWAY IN JUNE THIRD --
TO THOSE WHO KNEW HIM HE WAS
LIVE OR LOUIS YOUR WEB NO.
AND TO THOSE WHO LOVED HIM.
HE WAS DAD.
HE WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES IN.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE ATTENDED
MOUNT CARMEL HIGH SCHOOL.
IN LATER EL CAMINO COLLEGE AND
HE OFTEN TALKED ABOUT HIS YOUTH
IN LOS ANGELES WHERE HE HE WAS
VERY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT HE
SOLD.
THE HERALD EXAMINER AT THE
COLISEUM.
HE WORKED IN LOCAL STORES ANY
EARNED TWENTY FIVE CENTS FOR
EVERYONE THAT HE MODE --
HE LEFT COLLEGE TO GO WORK FOR
CHASE APPLIANCES IN INGLEWOOD.
HE MARRIED HIS WIFE OF FIFTY TWO
YEARS MY MOTHER LAW SWEETHEART
JO ELLAN.
MARRIED HER IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX IN SOON AFTER WE MOVED TO
ORANGE COUNTY.
OR HE COMMUTED TO LOS ANGELES
EVERY DAY TO RUN HIS SELF MADE
APPLIANCE REPAIR BUSINESS.
HEARING HIS PLUMBING CONTRACTORS
LICENSE AND ULTIMATELY RAN HIS
OWN PLUMBING BUSINESS.
WHERE HE PERFECTED THE ART OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION REMODELS IN AT
ONE TIME HE HAD MORE THAN 10% OF
ALL THE BUSINESS IN LAGUNA
NEWPORT BEACH?
HE MY MOTHER Y. HAD FOUR SONS
AND A DAUGHTER MUCH LIKE MY
HUSBAND AND I HOME.
HE DID NOT GET TO FINISH HIS
COLLEGE EDUCATION BECAUSE LIFE
HAPPENS SOMETIMES.
BUT HE MOST CERTAINLY MADE
EDUCATION A PRIORITY FOR HIS
CHILDREN TOGETHER.
ALL FIVE KIDS THEY HAVE THIRTEEN
COLLEGE DEGREES IN THERE ALL
PROFESSIONAL.
AND IT WAS BECAUSE OF HIM
ACTUALLY THAT I'M HERE --
TEN YEARS AGO HE IN MY HAS BEEN.
CONCOCTED THIS IDEA FOR ME TO
RUN FOR CITY COUNCIL AND THE
REST IS HISTORY.
EARLIER IN HIS LIFE HE WAS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE OLD MISSION
SCHOOL PARENT TEACHER
ORGANIZATION HE WAS THE ACT OF
MERCY IN ON CAPISTRANO LITTLE
LEAGUE.
THE BOY SCOUTS THE OLD MISSION
HISTORICAL EFFORTS HE WAS ALWAYS
THE COOK.
AT THE ANNUAL MISSION SCHOOL WAS
SPAGHETTI DINNER.
AND WHEN HIS KIDS WE'VE DONE
HIGH SCHOOL HE BECAME PRESIDENT
OF SAINT MICHAEL'S PARA GROUP
AND WENT ON TO BE THE COOK OF
THE ANNUAL FATHER'S DAY DEEP PIT
BARBECUE.
SO HE AND I SHARED A LOVE OF
COOKING --
WE ANNOY THE REST OF THE FAMILY
BY SITTING AND TALKING ABOUT
RECIPES BUT WE IT REALLY CARE
THAT THEY WERE ANNOYED WE HAD TO
TALK ABOUT.
WHETHER IS BEST A BY MASA OR
MAKE YOUR OWN BRING THE TURKEY
OR NUTS.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT TOPICS
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US --
HE HIS FAITH NEVER WAVERED.
AND I DO REMEMBER WHENEVER
SOMETHING WAS TROUBLING SOMEONE
[inaudible]
HE MOVES [inaudible]
HIS RESPONSE.
WAS ALWAYS GIVEN UP TO GOD
[inaudible]
HE'S [inaudible]
WHO [inaudible]
SO.
I'M I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING THROUGH THIS.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT HE LOVED.
HIS LITTLE DOG HENRY.
IN HIS FAMILY.
AND WE MISS HIM VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME.
THANK YOU MS MELENDEZ.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSING RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND DOCTOR CHEN SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL TUESDAY AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH.
AT TEN A. M. [inaudible]
WE ARCHER
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
AB.
TWO THREE THREE SEVEN VOTE
CHANGE NO TWO I VOTE CHANGE
SHOULD GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THROUGH THIRTY SEVEN NO
TO AYE